vous proposer de commencer cette séance
de notre commission d' enquête
avant de débuter je voudrais d'ailleurs
remercier d'abord notre collègue marie
mercier d'avoir présidé la séance
précédente avec efficacité
nous allons donc poursuivre nos travaux
par une édition commune de responsables
des services d'urgence chez nous sommes
très heureux d'accueillir aujourd'hui
donc le professeur louis soûlât qui est
chef du service des urgences du chu de
rennes et du samu l'idée vilaine le
docteur benoît doumenc êtes chef du
service des urgences médico
chirurgicales à l'hôpital cochin à paris
le docteur caroline brémaud qui est chef
du service des urgences du centre
hospitalier de laval le dr tarik boubia
qui est chef du service des urgences du
centre hospitalier de clamecy dans la
nièvre et le docteur françois escales
qui est médecin urgentiste libéral à la
clinique d'occitanie
au mur et de muret à muret à muret
je vous rappelle que cette audition est
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du sénat qu'elle fera l'objet d'un
compte rendu qui sera publiée services
d'urgence
excepté pour nous très important nous
entendre avec rapporteure catherine de
roche dès le début de ces travaux car
ils usent de manière à ce emblématique
les tensions que connaît notre système
hospitalier et les répercussions sur
l'hôpital d'un certain nombre de
dysfonctionnements dans l'organisation
des soins les urgences ont trait à ce
qui se passe en annonce ce qui se passe
en avaler ce qui se passe à l'intérieur
de l'hôpital
il paraissait donc nécessaire de vous
entendre vous qui êtes des acteurs de
terrain vous représenter toute la gamme
des établissements y compris privés
situés aussi bien dans des métropoles
dans des villes moyennes 2 que dans des
territoires ruraux
je vous remercie donc les uns les autres
de vous rendez vous est rendu à cette
convocation est parfois en venant de
bien loin avant de passer la parole à
notre rapporteur catherine de roche pour
quelques mots d'introduction je vous
rappelle que vous êtes devant une
commission denquête qu'un faux
témoignage est passible des peines
prévues aux articles 434 13 14 et 15 du
code pénal
je vais donc vous inviter invité chacun
d'entre vous a prêté serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité en
levant la main droite et en disant je le
jure professeur soula jeu du docteur
doumenc docteur escales
docteur brémaud docteur boubia je vous
remercie madame là à porter vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président je
voudrais à mon tour
la convocation est survenu à c'est assez
récemment
comme l'a indiqué le président lorsqu'on
parle des difficultés de l'hôpital ce
sont souvent les urgences que l'on cite
en premier leur activité à double en
battant les tensions dans les services
daval conduisent alors engorgement et la
crise sanitaire accentue ces phénomènes
mais à travers les urgences et aussi la
question du recours à l'hôpital de sa
place dans notre système de santé et de
sa vocation offrir un accès permanent
aux soit 24 heures sur 24 tous les jours
de l'année qu'est posée
donc nous souhaiterions que vous nous
présentez tout d'abord un point de la
situation de vos services respectifs
dans leur diversité notamment en matière
d'évolution d'activité d'effectifs de
conditions de prise en charge des
patients et nous pourrons ensuite évoqué
plus particulièrement à l'occasion des
questions les miennes aussi celle de mes
collègues les aspects liés aux
ressources humaines à la gestion de
l'amont des urgences permanence de soit
prise en charge de soins non programmés
et aux difficultés
d'hospitalisation en aval des urgences
donc je vous laisse la parole
merci à porter donc vous allez avoir
chacun la parole pour un exposé
introductif assez court on va dire 5 à 7
minutes si vous le pouvez après la
rapporteure vous posera les questions
qu'elles jugent nécessaires puis
l'ensemble de nos collègues membres de
la commission denquête professeurs sous
là on commence avec vous je voudrais si
si c'est possible faire un petit lien
avec
la nouveauté de la médecine d'urgence
qui est que c'est une spécialité qui est
jeune et j'avais préparé un petit
support sais pas s'il est possible de
donner la main pour rappeler que la
médecine d'urgence aujourd'hui
une jeune spécialité et on a vu arriver
en novembre 2020 tient la première
promotion de ses nouveaux à terme qui
sont nos futurs collègues et qui vont
nous remplacer dans quelques années est
ce qu'on aimerait c'est que l'on puisse
leur donner une vision différente de de
la médecine d'urgence pour leur donner
envie et je crois que c'est de notre
priorité aujourd'hui de donner la pretty
vite et sans coût de leur donner la
possibilité de vieillir comme urgentiste
dans un service d'urgence donc la
médecine d'urgence mais d'abord je
voudrais rappeler que je vais essayer de
passer en mode écran que c'est
que c'est une spécialité qui a trois
composantes on parle des sciences
hospitalière mais nous leur gentille
nous avons une activité de régulation
médicale samu est très importante dont
la base de fonctionnement et la loi de
l'amicale urgente nous avons une
activité pré hospitalière de soins
d'urgence avec les smur qui sont une
plus value pour le parcours des patients
et nous avons une activité de dans les
urgences hospitalières
qui est souvent celle dont on parle de
façon très négative avec des patients de
des patients sont braqués en parallèle
en parallèle notre coeur de métier
l'urgence aujourd'hui et c'est ce que
beaucoup de collègues ont oublié que ce
soit les collègues de de la ville que ce
soit les collègues de l'hospitalier
notre coeur de métier cee qualifier un
besoin de soins évalué trier orienté et
on organise des filières de soins et
c'est la grande force de notre système
en france qui est un système assez
exceptionnel c'est qu'on organise des
parcours de soins très spécialisés pour
des soins aigus je parlais d'infarctus
d'accident vasculaire cérébral des
choses auxquelles on est tous confrontés
aujourd'hui et qui ont pu montrer leur
excellence et donc concrètement et bien
on a cette spécialité de médecine
d'urgence qui aujourd'hui voit arriver
les premiers les premiers urgentistes
avec une formation de quatre ans le
problème c'est que notre coeur de métier
il était il était centré est censé être
centré sur ce cette notion de
dévaluation de tri d'orienter donc sur
la prise en charge initiale du parcours
de soins mais on doit subir une activité
très forte qui est lié à tout ce qui
relève de ce que vous avez appelé
lamont donc des patients qui viennent
aux urgences qui pourrait selon nous
être géré par des soins des structures
de soins non programmés et également par
tout ce qui relève de l'aval des
urgences et qui en 30 parties et est
représenté par les soins des patients à
donner aux patients polypathologiques ce
terme est un petit peu
qui souvent résume des patients qui sont
âgés qui ont des patients des
pathologies multiples est qu'ils n'ont
pas de service aujourd'hui du fait de la
réorganisation des services qui y perd
spécialisés avec le virage ambulatoire a
conduit à des réorganisations de lit qui
aujourd'hui sont sait parfaitement
démontré insuffisant en parallèle depuis
2002 et bien l'âme ans a été marqué par
une activité qui relève pour nous des
soins non programmés des patients qui
viennent parce qu'ils n'ont plus accès à
leur médecin traitant et donc c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'offre ambulatoire avec
un paradigme qui a été un virage qui a
été très nette en 2002 dès lors qu' il
ya une règle ouardi réorganisation
nécessaire de la médecine de ville qui
s'est en partie traduite par une
réorganisation de permanence des soins
basés sur le volontariat
tout ça pour dire que la situation
aujourd'hui elle est extrêmement
compliqué
alors oui un petit bémol en plus c'est
le principe qui avait été mis en place
dans les hôpitaux la tarification à
l'activité qui sur les urgences se
concrétiser par vous avez plus
d'activité parce qu'il ya plus de
permanence des soins mais vous allez
faire plus d'activités dont vous aurez
plus de financement donc tout ça c'était
une façon un petit peu donné qu paix sur
notre activité alors notre coeur de
métier eh bien il est performant il nous
permet de nous apporter un bénéfice
important pour les patients avec une
spécialité qui est attractif pour le
soin papier pour nos urgentistes des
filières performante cependant et puis
en plus qui repose et c'est pour ça que
je suis là le public depuis 35 ans
j'étais ce choix là parce qu'il repose
sur un principe d'équité d'accès aux
soins pour tous de la même qualité c'est
le principe de leval médical urgent pour
donner une réponse adaptée et bien en
parallèle l'impact aujourd'hui du report
d'activité sur les urgences qui ne sont
pas du métier d'urgence
eh bien on a une éducation très moyen et
l'évolution de notre activité on a un
épuisement des équipes on a la
satisfaction de l'impression de travail
inachevé qui conduit dans beaucoup
d'établissements
départ et là des départs et des
orientations en masse des médecins et
des soignants et c'est pour ça qu'il ya
une vraie inquiétude pour les fêtes de
fin d'année parce qu'on a un tiers des
services qui sont énormes difficultés
avec l'impossibilité de tenir toutes les
lignes de garde dont notamment le
service de laval de caroline primo elle
portera tout à l'heure et on est voisins
mais également un tiers des services qui
eux du fait de l'activité majeure
actuelle liée en partie aux copines mais
pas que ce mouvement c'est aujourd'hui
que la crise que l'on vit actuellement
la cinquième vague elle est complètement
différente des autres le coc vide ça
représente un nombre de patients qui est
relativement basse par rapport à ce
qu'on a pu connaître par contre on est
dans un système hyper saturé de lits
d'aval ou pas donc on aujourd'hui une
offre almaty pour l'ozone gens gentils
ce sera mon conducteur comment donner de
l'attractivité et surtout donné envie de
travailler l'hôpital pendant des années
le système hospitalier monsieur madame
il est trop complexe et trop complexe et
on a besoin d'adaptabilité dans nos
services d'urgence on a su le faire par
la crise qu vide mais il ya eu un retour
en arrière complet après le ségur et ce
qui creuse encore un petit peu le fossé
entre la direction et les soignants on
ne peut pas avoir une gestion compte
purement comptable de nos de nos
services on doit être capable d'adapter
des moyens en fonctions d'activité alors
certes je les dis notre coeur de métier
il est largement dépassée mais au moins
qu'on nous permette de mettre en place
des organisations pour le tiers des
services qui sont en difficulté et non
pas aux autres ain d'effectifs mais à
cause de problèmes de suractivité
donc il faut également valoriser les
métiers des soignants ça on en a je
pense que vous en avez entendu parler
par plein de comptes présentation les
soignants ils seront en souffrance alors
il ya eu bien sûr les effets du ségur
qui ont été sur le ce des salaires mais
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut
humaniser les métiers et surtout qu'on
arrête de deux d'opposer les catégories
de soignants entre eux trop souvent on
remplace des aides soignants dans les
services contenus sur chance par des
infirmiers c'est pas les mêmes soins
c'est pas les mêmes métiers les patients
ont besoin des soignants on a des
hôpitaux avec des ambulanciers qui sont
en grève depuis depuis des mois et dont
on ne parle pas qu'ils ont besoin d'une
reconnaissance de leur statut pourquoi
pourquoi on leur donne pas la même
catégorie de soignants et on nous
explique le niveau des directions
hospitalières que c'est pas les mêmes
grilles salariales c'est trop complexe
et surtout ça démotive des
professionnels qui sont pourtant très
engagé ça a été démontrée et puis
surtout il ya une déqualification de la
médecine d'urgence avec une confusion
qui est entretenue par certains en
mélangeant le public sokouri les soins
urgents alors là je vais pas entrer dans
un sujet très politique et la médecine
d'urgence et des soins d'urgence et de
secours c'est autre chose et comme je
lui ai dit notre métier c'est la
médecine d'urgence hospitalière extra
hospitalières et donc les smur ce ne
sont pas des secours ce sont des soins
d'urgence et de réanimation de qualité
et donc 7,7 cette confusion qui en
contenus auprès du grand public eh bien
elle se traduit à travers une loi qui
pour lequel on est particulièrement
opposés sur la notion d'un numéro unique
pour les secours en france et d'air
qu'il faut aujourd'hui j'en parlais tout
à l'heure à la fin sur si on veut
maîtriser laval là mon pardon c'est le
sas qui doit nous aider alors cette
vision l'urgence aujourd'hui c'est ce
qui nous dérange le plus c'est l'image
qui en est donnée par les médias les
publics jeu responsable d'un service
d'urgences qui étaient 65 mille passages
actuellement comment ce qu'on parle des
urgences hospitalières aujourd'hui c'est
des patients sur brancard une
maltraitance des patients des délais
d'attentes des services saturé une perte
de chance une pénibilité du travail les
départs ainsi des urgences oil à l'image
que l'on donne depuis des années les
services d'urgence alors que le pack de
refondation prévoyez qu'on arrive un
petit peu inversé la courbe de tendance
même chose un petit peu les avis de nos
collègues des services d'aval il est
quand même assez extraordinaire on
considère que les serbes les patients
qui sont urgence qui se sont souvent se
disant nos patients viennent perturber
les organisations on a trop orienté
aujourd'hui sur le soin non programmés
les services en réorganisation les lits
d'aval aujourd'hui on voit bien que si
on est dans une impasse parce que on
oppose trop souvent le programme et nos
programmes et alors qu'on a des flux
prévisibles aux urgences qui permettrait
un petit peu d'anticiper sur les fuites
passion en période épidémique est encore
une fois cette confusion
qui auprès du public est entretenue
entre soins d'urgence et secours et sap
pour nous c'est très difficile
d'imaginer qu'on puisse être sous la
coupe d'un ministère qui n'est pas celui
de la santé
le ressenti des heures des urgentistes
aujourd'hui est bien c'est qu'il ya une
désaffection avant d'être universitaire
que je suis un peu de la filière je
m'appelle le professeur locaux ce parce
que j'ai passé trente ans dans un
service
d'hôpital rural en berry dans l'indre
est passé 30 ans dans cet hôpital l'aa
doit faire face à toutes les
problématiques de désertification
médicale et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui ce
que l'on ressent c'est que les
urgentistes ont l'impression qu'il ya il
y à une désinfection de décollecte des
signes de ville pour la permanence des
soins ambulatoires qui est pourtant le
leur de leur compétence on constate des
déséquilibres très fort de notamment en
terme de pénibilité la charge de travail
parce qu'on est un des rares des rats
spécialité assurer une permanence des
soins et ça passe aussi par des
différences de rémunération est ce qui
fait qu on va se retrouver dans une
salle de régulation avec des praticiens
qui font à peu près le même métier de
régulation médicale avec des des statuts
et des rémunérations complètement
différentes qui sont parfois blessantes
à tel point que
certains font le choix de quitter
l'hôpital pour cet argument là ce qu'est
ce qui est regrettable bien sûr
l'hôpital aussi a souffert vous le savez
du recours à l'intérim alors certes la
loire east devrait contrôler tout ça
mais ces déséquilibres est important la
réalité c'est que les urgences sont la
seule lumière allumée et là il nous faut
un contrôle de l'accès aux services
d'urgence aujourd'hui si on veut que le
flux d urgence au contrôle et il faut
que ça passe par un accès qui passe par
un numéro d'urgence et tout ça bien sûr
pour donner deux envie aux urgentistes
de continuer il faut donner de
l'attractivité aux médecins urgentistes
alors ça passe par une diversification
de l'activité il faut décider d
organisation adaptée en double
gouvernance
direction est responsable de service il
faut harmoniser et simplifier les
statuts je remet encore l'exemple des
ambulanciers qui sont en grève depuis
des mois tout simplement parce qu'on les
a pas
mis dans la catégorie b qu'on nous aide
soignant par exemple il faut être
capable d'organiser nos équipes avec une
évolution de l'activité on peut pas être
gentil j'ai 60 ans je fais encore huit à
dix cas par mois ce n'est pas normal on
est un des rares services avoir une
telle pénibilité et on considère que
l'activité de garder la même pour un
jeune urgentiste un ancien c'est pas
normal et puis en plus le grand oublié
du c ur c'est la pénibilité de la pds
alors il faut organiser l'aval des
urgences et ça il faut des cellules de
gestion des lits qui soit structurée au
niveau d'un territoire et puis 24 heures
sur 24 et non pas sur des bouts de
journée
on s'est organisé laval aujourd'hui avec
le principe de b j ml c'est le besoin
journalier moyen en lit on sait qu'il ya
des périodes de tension tous les ans qui
sont reproductibles et donc on a des
flux qui sont prévisibles
malheureusement on n'arrive pas à le
mettre en place tout simplement parce
que le programme est dans les hôpitaux
prédomine sur les ont programmées lors
que ce sont pourtant les patients de
toutes les lieux de toutes les
spécialités et pour répondre aux
problèmes de laval effectivement il ya
il faut répondre aux besoins de santé la
population et laval c'est aussi l'aval
de l'aval il n'y a pas que les services
hospitaliers qui doivent prendre en
charge les patients a sorti des urgences
il ya aussi toutes les structures qui
doivent permettre un retour à domicile
dans de bonnes conditions et enfin pour
terminer et bien si on veut contrôler la
mon jeu je pense je suis intimement
convaincu que l'expérimentation recourse
des services d'accès aux soins c'est la
priorité il faut développer ces systèmes
d'accès aux soins qui vont nous
permettre à nous
médecins hospitaliers et médecins
médecins de de médecine générale de la
de la permanence des soins d'organiser
des vrais parcours de soins adaptés à
leurs besoins de santé et surtout
diminuer le passage aux urgences et ça
passe mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
par un numéro d'urgence santé
cette réorganisation de la pds à
elle est importante aussi il va falloir
s'interroger sur ce problématique de la
participation aux gardes de l'ensemble
des collègues et puis et là aussi c'est
une question sur lequel vous aurez à
débattre je pense que c'est un sujet
important
on a actuellement plus de 600 structures
d'urgence en france est-ce qu'il faut
maintenir toutes ces structures ouvertes
en nuit profonde
on à l'arrivée des nouvelles
autorisations
de services d'urgence qui vont permettre
d ouverture sur les inquiétudes limité
peut-être qu'il faut accepter le
principe de fermer à certaines d'urgence
des structures d'urgence à faible
activité pour maintenir les cieux l'est
et lé smur qui assure les soins
d'urgence et renforcé en parallèle les
services qui accueillent les plaçant à
orienter en nuit profonde donc ça c'est
un vrai débat et pour cela il faudra
certainement une grande pédagogie auprès
de nos élus et des politiques parce que
pour l'avoir vécu dans une vie qui
s'appelle vitré on a réussi à fermer la
nuit pour l'instant depuis un an un
service la nuit et ça se passe plutôt
pas mal tout simplement parce qu'on a
fait la pédagogie on a travaillé avec
les élus les les responsables
hospitaliers de service pour trouver une
solution adaptée aux besoins des
patients je remercie excusez moi d'avoir
été aussi maire si on sait que
l'exercice est compliqué voilà
juste un point je voudrais rappeler que
le projet de loi dont vous avez parlé
est une loi maintenant projet de loi dit
ma trace a été adopté définitivement par
le parlement docteur demain que
je fais j'ai essayé d'être un site et
concis déjà juste me me présenter parce
que je pense que vous allez demander de
venir aussi par rapport à nos
expériences aussi personnelle et
individuelle moi je suis médecin
généraliste je crois qu'on partage avec
certains autour de cette table c'est de
cette spécialité et comme certains aussi
j'ai exercé en tant que médecin
généraliste en banlieue dans 92 pendant
plusieurs années et à l'époque devant la
difficulté de cet exercice en médecine
libérale l'absence d'horaires et c'est
tout j'ai choisi pour d'autres raisons
évidemment aussi le rgs regagné
l'hôpital est en tout cas très
clairement un d une des raisons pour
lesquelles j'ai arrêté la médecine
générale c'était parce que je me sentais
un peu isolé je retrouve au niveau des
services d'urgence qu'on est beaucoup
plus on travaille en équipe et c'était
et ses témoins à volonté et ensuite en
terme de pénibilité je tiens à le dire
aussi le métier de médecin libéral
médecin généraliste est un métier aussi
qu' en terme d'horaires est aussi sans
limite et que c'est et c'était une des
raisons pour lesquelles en médecine
d'urgence à l'époque on avait des
horaires ter ont commencé à telle heure
on finissait alors lagarde se faisait et
c'est tout pas de difficulté ensuite
j'ai participé mois à la restructuration
de plusieurs services d'urgence en ile
de france d'abord à l'assistance
publique hôpitaux de paris à l'hôpital
du kremlin bicêtre il ya un très très
très très très longtemps puis ensuite tu
es partie de la création d urgence de
bichat c'était avant avant mon arrivée
bien évidemment mais avec le professeur
casalino on a mis en place un certain
organisations de services d'urgence avec
maintenant un service qui a plus de 200
voire 250 passages jour je crois je ne
peux pas en vouloir à mentir là dessus
et ensuite on dire tellement tapé sur le
dos des chefs de service en disant c'est
pas possible ils font n'importe quoi
pendant que nous on est à la mine c'est
pas possible alors qu'henrik pas du tout
dans cette dans cette optique là loin de
là j'ai pris la responsabilité des
urgences l'hôpital delafontaine en 93 un
service qui était complètement perdition
totale et avec l'aide des équipes tant
médicales que paramédical on a
restructuré et refait de ce service un
service qui tournait avec une
organisation qui permettait en tout cas
d'absorber et de diminuer certes la
pénibilité est aussi d'améliorer la
prise en charge des patients et enfin
cela fait maintenant six ou sept ans que
j'ai pris la responsabilité d'un du
service des urgences de l'accueil de
cochin et hôtel dieu s'il vous plaît
donc service qui à l'époque était aussi
dans une grande difficulté et on a
progressivement avec l'aide de mon
adjointe le professeur florence du
maquis elle est aussi une pure j'allais
dire urgentistes internes de médecine
d'urgence contrairement à moi qui ne
suis qu'un généraliste avec une capacité
des signes d'urgence plus d'autres
personnes on en a fait maintenant une
structure où nous n'avons quasiment un
effectif complet sur le plan médical le
plan paramédical on est aussi
globalement bien mieux lotis que le
reste de l'hôpital nous sommes en
difficulté mais nous sommes encore une
fois très privilégié et j'ai la chance
et j'ai eu la chance je tiens à dire
aussi tout au long de mon exercice
hospitalier temps pendant 93 que au
niveau de l'ap-hp de rencontrer en local
une direction que laquelle je pouvais
discuter puis qu'ils entendaient et qui
répondait où on était parfaitement
conscient les uns et les autres des
difficultés les obligations de certains
temps le dit dans l'administration sur
des problèmes
administratifs de gestion de
rentabiliser tous vont vous peu importe
là dessus c'est trop compliqué je ne
rentrerai pas là dedans mais aussi
complètement capacités 2
de faire des efforts ne nous donnait des
lignes de garde lorsqu on en avait
besoin d'autres encore seront les
justifier et non pas en disant c'est
difficile il faut que on montrait qu' on
arrivait à démontrer et surtout petit à
petit on a réussi à donner un service
c'est très du local on est bien d'accord
là-dessus qui a fonctionné plutôt pas
mal maintenant je dirais pour rebondir
un petit peu sur ce que ce qu'a dit le
professeur louis soûlât je partage
complètement son analyse globale sur la
france mais je dirais aussi qu'il n'ya
pas un service d'urgence qui ressemble à
un autre service d'urgence et que
finalement la pratique que vous avez
vous à laval celle-ci ou en tout cas n
est certainement pas la même que la
mienne je peux avoir au niveau de
l'assistance publique-hôpitaux de paris
à cochin nous avons peu de malades très
graves qui arrivent nous au niveau de
nos urgences grâce à la régulation donc
qui est fait en amont d'accord avec
aussi à une offre de soins de services
de soins critiques qui évidemment est
sans commune mesure en région parisienne
rapport à d'autres régions de france
encore une fois je pense qu'il n'y a pas
un problème d'urgence il ya bien sûr des
grands principes de grandes difficultés
que nous rencontrons tous et qui sortent
évidemment diminué en fonction de
l'endroit on peut exercer ses très
claire
bardon ensuite je n'ai que le service
dont je m'occupe donc au choc
particulièrement on est en moyenne je
pars pas en cinquante mille etc pour moi
ça représente pas grand chose c'est un
chiffre qui peut peu parlant on est en
moyenne entre 160 et 190 passages par
jour au niveau de cochin
avec ce taux là qui a augmenté qui avait
évidemment diminué pendant la cause vide
/ paris / intra muros et on a repris une
activité qui est un peu au dessus de
celle que l'on avait même nettement au
dessus c'est qu'on avait avant la
pandémie ce qui change surtout c'est pas
tant le nombre de passages peu importe
quand on est en effectif médical
suffisant en effective para médical
suffisant je fais partie de ceux qui
disent que le nombre de passages
n'importe que je suis en capacité encore
une fois un effectif constant complet de
voir rapidement ses patients et de les
réorienter comme le dit comme le dit oui
ou en tout cas les traiter rapidement et
de l'oeil depuis de pouvoir ensuite
qu'il quitte ses urgences ce qu'on a
très clairement maintenant c'est
l'augmentation du taux d'hospitalisation
avant la colline dans ma structure on
était à 14% à peu près de split et des
sons je sais pas quel est le taux exact
dont vous différence était une telle 14%
actuellement on est plutôt près des 20 %
20 % d'hospitalisation c'est en tout cas
vous j'ai prêté serment
dans 1% toutefois on a une baisse aussi
du nombre de dix nouvelles alors moi je
fais partie des gens gentils dit on
arrête maintenant de dire on n'a pas
assez dit et c'est tout maintenant il
faut aussi que
les différentes spécialités dans
l'hôpital aussi prennent conscience de
la nécessité de réorganiser leurs
services bien sûr en tenant compte de
toutes les complexités qu'ils peuvent
avoir et contenait aussi la possibilité
que nos patients qui sont aux urgences
puisse monter lorsque le lit est libre
rapidement dans les élevages vous savez
comme moi vous travaillez en ville mais
que moi quand j'ai des patients j'ai
très peu de leaders lg expliquer
pourquoi j'ai peu près de lille c'est
peut être m de vide à mal par contre
j'ai une accessibilité au lit qui est
très complexe le patient est acceptée
dans mon service daval de médecine
interne la décision a été prise à 10
heures du matin il va monter à 16 heures
pour plein de raisons que je ne pourrai
on pourrait détailler mais donc il ya
tout ça donc on a perdu déjà clairement
une journée d'hospitalisation pour le
patient je ne parle pas de rentabilité
je parle d'efficacité pour la prise en
charge du patient
ensuite non excusez-moi donc nous avons
moi j'ai la chance d'avoir pratiquement
jamais de libre en car pratiquement
jamais de livre en gage on a une
fluidité mais nous sommes à effectif
constant et ça a très clairement ça
permet aussi de fluidifier et de prendre
en charge en plus quand on est en
effectif constante par le médecin senior
les décisions sont prises évidemment
plus rapidement on est moins fatigué on
peut réfléchir mieux et c'est évident
que les conditions de travail sont
indispensables et je rejoins
complètement je pense que vont il ya
l'ensemble de mes collègues pour
beaucoup de services d'urgence les
conditions de travail sont inacceptables
inacceptables pour plein de raisons mais
il faut aussi que l'hôpital travaille
dans le même sens que tout le travail le
8 à 13 ans même sens pourquoi on a moins
de difficultés au niveau nous pour
trouver des lits d'aval c'est parce que
je suis désolé mais moi j'ai une machine
de guerre le matin vous dirai très très
à la mode a été prolongée il a été
prononcée à la suite de la colline qui
nous a impacté moi j'ai une machine de
guerre tous les matins où j'ai la chance
d'avoir
ellul de gestion des lits qui présente
et qui a une vraie efficacité qui
présente tous les jours de la semaine
qui n'appartient pas aux urgences
surtout pas sinon c'est encore les
urgentistes qui met le binz qui
appartient à l'ensemble du si l'hôpital
et on a réussi on est en train plutôt de
réussir à faire comprendre à nos
collègues d'autres spécialités que cette
cellule de gestion des lits leur
permettra lorsqu'ils sont en
consultation plutôt que d'envoyer mal
aux urgences parce qu'ils ont rappelé
leurs cadres qui ne trouvent pas vivre
dans leur service d'appeler cette
cellule de gestion desdites qu'il va
pouvoir à condition qu'il y ait délit le
nerf de la guerre il faut qu'il y ait
des et bien ce patient pourra aller dans
un autre service non pas pour être
hébergé le mot hébergement jeu le banni
de son vocabulaire
c'est là où il ya des dangers parce que
quand on héberge un patient cardiologie
je n'ai rien contre les cardiologues en
gastro entérologie je n'ai rien contre
les gastro entérologue et bien le
gastro-entérologue va ne va pas ce qu'on
va faire de l'hôtellerie et là ça n'est
pas bien là on est dans la mauvaise
gestion
donc à ce moment là il faut vraiment que
cette cette cellule italie nous aide
beaucoup et véritablement ça nous a
transformé la vie aussi nous avons une
population âgée importante nous avons la
chance d'avoir une équipe mobile de
gériatrie qui a un rôle fantastique
parce que et ont rejoint tout à fait ce
que disait louis notre rôle c'est aussi
d'orienter de trier d'orienter les
patients eh bien ces patients certains
vont aller vers les structures de
gériatrie j'ai eu la chance d'avoir un
président de cmu l ancien qui a eu une
bonne vision et qui a demandé à
augmenter le nombre de lits de gériatrie
aiguë quand les gens se parlent quand
les gens vont dans le même sens ça
diminue quand même un certain nombre de
choses il est très clair qu actuellement
tout ce que je vous dis là vous avez
vous dire c'est enfin un urgentiste
peut-être qui vous semblent heureux et
content c'est vrai mais là il ya des
limites avec la fermeture des lits qui
est lié au manque de personnel là très
clairement toute organisation aussi
bonne soit elle
j'ai la prétention de croire que ce
qu'on a mis en place sur que chaque une
organisation qui tient la route puisque
je vous rappelle simplement que nous
sommes un des services les plus rapides
plus fréquemment choisis par les
internes de spécialités sur paris pour
être formés à la médecine d'urgence tous
profils confondus
malgré cela avec ces diminutions
drastiques du nom d'elie encore face au
cauchemar n'est épargné par rapport à
d'autres hôpitaux de la paix le système
ne fonctionne pas à mon sens
nous sommes au niveau de l'hôpital au
bout d'un système voilà
merci docteur ès cas
je me présente un petit peu plus
l'hospitalisation privée je suis donc
comme mes confrères qui un médecin
généraliste eu l'air là camus j'exerce
avait une urgence depuis un peu plus de
24 ans et d'un service d'urgences privée
je suis également régulateur au sein du
centre 15 en permanence de soins
ambulatoires et du service accès au soir
le fameux sas et pour compléter le
tableau je suis également fier de
réserve du service santé des armées
depuis 20 ans je vous remercie d'avoir
convié pour porter la voix de mes
confrères urgentistes libéraux qui
exercent dans les 120 structures
d'urgence privé autres pays clients
agences privées ça représente à peu près
15 % des presque 24 millions de passages
annuels aux urgences ça fait à peu près
3 millions et demi avec de fortes
disparités sur un département en effet
15 % cela reste conséquent mais pas
énorme en revanche sur une île comme
toulouse par exemple les urgences privé
ça représente 50% du total des passages
annuels et c'est la même chose nous
nombreuses grandes agglomérations de ce
pays
les services d'urgences privé fonctionne
exactement comme les autres les médecins
qui exercent ont reçu la même formation
dans les mêmes 6 h il est même aux
hôpitaux périphériques et aucune
sélection de patience aux quelques
critères que ce soit seuls les capacités
en termes d'effectifs et le plateau
technique
interviennent pour récuser certains
patients proposé par la régulation du
fait de carences techniques ou de
spécialité
donc c'est un appel au secours que je
vous fais aujourd'hui pour en avoir
discuté avec les infirmières et les
aides-soignantes les agents de
régulation médicale du samu 31 mai
confère une urgentiste de l'hôpital
public et du privé vous prendrez car de
régulation mais son frère médecins
généralistes de ville et mes collègues
spécialistes nous sommes tous épuisés
physiquement et nerveusement
j'ai pas de solution miracle il est
certain que la situation actuelle ne
peut plus continuer un médecin
généraliste déborder les urgences une
consultation spécialité déborder les
urgences désert médical les urgent cinq
cabinets fermés les urgences des délais
de rendez vous allongez vision gérance
un centre 15 déborder les urgences et
les urgences france quelle forme depuis
des années parce que j'appelle pour
rigoler les 3t tout tout le temps tout
de suite
pour faire de la médecine il faut des
médecins des infirmières des aides
soignantes des ae sache comme à l'hôtel
public nous faisons face à des vagues de
démission et pour en avoir dix longues
en discuter avec elle surtout les
infirmières elles craquent faire
toujours plus avec toujours moins
c'était plus possible vous donner un
ordre d'idée j'exerce d'une petite ville
au sud de toulouse une petite clinique
avec 200 lits d'hospitalisation
le service des urgences accueillent
trente six mille personnes par an quand
nous l'avons ouvert il ya 23 ans on a
commencé à y avait six mille personnes
qui venaient tous les ans une
progression significative
il ya six médecins qui va l'entendre
nous sommes de la journée tout seul la
nuit le médecine douvres d'urgence nous
sommes passés à de la médecine de
catastrophe avec un afflux massif de
blessés sauf que c'est une catastrophe
permanente le chu ne s'arrête jamais il
peut ralentir un petit peu la nuit mais
ne s'arrête jamais nous avons des
équipes épuisé et pourtant dieu sait
qu'ils aimeraient essayer d'en prendre
soin comme l'ont déjà dit mes confrères
nous sommes nous aussi confronté au
poids d'une administration vais dire
folz pas très gentil de formulaires de
protocoles de réunionite de référentiels
de normes chronophage et sans intérêt
réel pour le qr2 souhaitiez le patient
reçoit
depuis des années le système essaye
désespérément de faire rentrer la
médecine dans des cases comme cela est
impossible on tape former un carré déjà
mes rentes et un vin rond cela fait des
années que nous tirons la sonnette
d'alarmé et chaque année nous arrivons à
nous de nous y arrivions nous passions
la période hivernale qui est
classiquement la plus rude en 2017
l'épidémie de grippe fait plus
importante que d'habitude et je me
souviens partir travailler la boule au
ventre un service plein des ambulances
qui continuellement arrivé sans aucun
libre en car pour accueillir cette année
nous allons nous risquons d'avoir la
grippe et le co vide et je crains une
passion pas nous sommes débordés
submergés main à tous les niveaux le ch
est revenu dans sa partie régulation
fait face à des volumes d'appels ingère
après j'étais dimanche dernier nous
avons fini la journée à plus de 1700
dossier des temps d'attentes après
décrocher et avant les régulations qui
sont montés à 1h40 1h40 de musique si le
rond et quand il ya trop d'appels trop
de temps attendons réguler un peu moins
bien on en droit vers les urgences est
normal ça m'est arrivé à moi aussi on a
trop aller aux urgences
les deux bornes faite par le président
de la fhf aux médecins libéraux de
reporter leurs congés de fin d'année où
le directeur de l'ap-hp de racheter les
périodes de congé pour quelques milliers
d'euros au sauna une manoeuvre de
cavalerie effectivement si cela peut
fonctionner pour qu'elles quelques
semaines mais guère plus
et comme je le disais plus haut pour
faire de la médecine il faut des
médecins et des soignants
une étude récente montre que 50% des
médecins sont au bord du burn out les
confrères ont beaucoup se désengage et
cher des activités moins intense
psychologiquement parlant alors pour en
parler vous dit tout représentant
officiel je suis là le énième rejeton
d'une vieille dynastie musicale
toulousaine c'est à dire que j'entends
parler de médecine depuis la naissance
avec un père professeur d'université un
an pour que ces diversités un grand
oncle un grand père en arrière grand
père il faut quand même le plus ancien
était né à la fin des dix huitième jeu
vous dire si je baigne dedans quelque
temps déjà et donc je vais évoluer la
médecine et les médecins le système de
lits de 2021 en place depuis quelques
années a réussi à faire disparaître la
sérénité chez le médecin et c'est
important à sérénité lorsque vous
remettez votre diplôme votre vie en jeu
à chaque patient lorsque le risque
médico-légal devient fou cela vous amène
à faire venir et pas une mauvaise
médecine mais nous finissons et c'est
humain par penser par moment où
plusieurs nouveaux patients le ray grass
notre système de soins au bord de
l'implosion et ce n'est plus une figure
de style nous sommes tous en train d'y
laisser notre peau lorsque je prends ma
garde que je récupère des confrères en
larmes et les infirmières on pleure
c'est pas normal c'est indigne d'un pays
comme le nôtre je n'accable personne
mais c'est les résidences 40 ans de
politique de santé basée sur une gestion
industrielle de la médecine il n'y a pas
d'économies d'échelle en médecine les
regroupe les gros hôpitaux de réalise
que très peu d'économies d'échelle ou
vraiment à la marque et on ne gère pas
un hôpital pour une usine de petits pois
faut des humains en poney les humains et
maintenant il va falloir s'occuper des
soignants c'est une priorité absolue
sans soignant il plus de médecine et les
drames sont à venir il ya quelques mois
j'ai discuté avec le directeur du samu
31 le professeur bonne à la suite d'une
récriminations des pompiers sur le fait
que certains médecins urgentistes avait
pas été marc lecteurs actifs pas
question combien de fois cela serait-il
arrivé la réponse a été une fois par
mois soit niche fois par an sur trente
six mille passages et c'est comme
pourcentage d'erreurs du samu 31 qui
doit être la même dans tous les samu de
france un peu de choses près ce
pourcentage c'est le cas pour mille ça
veut dire 99 6% le succès mais non on
regarde les 4 pour mille et les douze
fois par an ou l'urgentiste épuisé un
mot de travers ou peut faire une haie
guère eu une erreur de régulation ce qui
nous est tous arrivé regardons ce qui
fonctionne prenons soin des médecins
favorisant les passerelles entre le
public et le privé décloisonnement
simplifions et redon le pouvoir à ceux
qui savent la cécité de médecine
d'urgence le fameux des semis avec un
exercice exclusif en services d'urgences
des médecins formés à l'urgence absolue
laisser celle du 4 et 5 qui représente
un petit peu moins de 2% des passages
d'un exemple de la fausse bonne idée
réorienter ses joueurs les 98%
restaurant je veux bien mais qui va le
faire il va faire des futurs ce qui va
faire des plâtres qui va s'occuper de
ces gens là personne d'autre la nuit à
partir de minuit il ya plus que nous
l'ouvert il ya plus de permanences de
soins ambulatoires
il ya plus un médecin généraliste de
garde le seul truc ou vert s'il est
libre lance donc un urgentiste une sont
des médecins généralistes ont fait tous
ont fait de du rhume jusqu'à d'infarctus
à l'envolée de piles moser ou à l'avc
nous allons reprendre toutes les bonnes
volontés la formation des internes doit
également se faire dans le privé un
stage c'est pas énorme et à terme cela
rendra plus fluides les discussions
publiques et v fera disparaître et
inimitiés dû à une méconnaissance du
travail de l'autre même métier même
serment même patient utiliser au mieux
les compétences optimisant les
ressources disponibles et il y en a
encore un tout petit peu une direction
comme l'a
décrété la loi hpst
totalement administrative ne fonctionne
pas et ne fonctionnera jamais
l'administration au service des médecins
et des soignants pas l'un vertes et pour
conclure je réitère un appel au secours
pour l'ensemble des médecins et
personnels soignants ce pays nous sommes
à bout donc en train de craquer toute
forme de contraintes supplémentaires ne
fera qu'augmenter l'hémorragie de
compétences comme vous le savez reste
l'on a remplacé remettant du bon sens de
l'humanité et de la gentillesse arrêtez
de nous transformer en machine à soigner
cela ne marche pas aidez-nous être à
continuer à être fidèles à notre serment
merci donc ça reste qu'à et je crois que
c'était plus que nécessaire d'entendre
non seulement vous qui exerçait dans le
secteur public mais également dans le
secteur privé ça montre bien l'unité de
vécu des problèmes auxquels auxquelles
vous faites face docteur brémaud
alors je vais faire un état des lieux de
ce que je connais le mieux c'est la
situation au centre hospitalier de laval
qui fait partie des villes moyennes donc
on draine un bassin de population de
cent mille habitants on a 35 mille
passages par un mont et l'hôpital
support du département le support
du j'ai acheté voilà on est trois
médecins la journée de la nuit on a des
en termes d externe on accueille aussi
des docteurs junior on a un beau plateau
technique on a une réelle une
réanimation polyvalente une salle de
coronarographie la pédiatrie des
chirurgies de diverses spécialités une
maternité de niveau 2b
depuis dix ans on a eu une augmentation
de notre activité
d'environ 20%
au niveau des effectifs médicaux en mai
à 5 équivalents temps plein pour une
cible entre 16 et 18 pour fonctionner
correctement et on est en dessous de
moins de trois équivalents temps-plein
avoir le droit d'exercer la nuit
il ya dix ans n'était pas beaucoup plus
en fait j'ai regardé j'étais étonné on
était 6,5 et en fait on avait un recours
à l'intérim qui était plus facile
actuellement le recours à l'intérim est
difficile parce qu'on a une perte
d'attractivité dans l'établissement qui
est lié au fait qu'on a une grande
pénibilité de travail on apprit
équivalent les intérimaires préfère
aller travailler dans des structures
plus petites où la charge de travail est
moins importante donc on a recours à
l'intérim qui est quasi inexistant on a
un temps additionnel qui est colossal on
est à 400 500 heures par an
on a on a un manque d'effectif
paramédicaux sur l'établissement il
manque 30 cette infirmière sur notre
hôpital on a perdu 60 lits
en 18 mois on est passé de 340 à 280
concernant la prise en charge des
patients
je crois que le mot indigne et le plus
simple et le plus parlant pour tout le
monde on peut attendre plusieurs heures
avant d'être pris en charge cette
semaine j'ai une dame de 95 ans qui
restait trente six heures dans le
couloir des urgences
on souhaite ça à aucun sauf aucun membre
de sa famille c'est juste intolérables
chaque nuit j'ai plusieurs personnes qui
dans dans le couloir des urgences
avant la crise qu'au guidon affichés sur
les murs le nombre de personnes qui
dormaient dans les couloirs pour des
raisons sanitaires on a arrêté de mettre
des feuilles sur les murs mais les
personnes sont toujours là on a des
patients qui doivent uriner derrière un
petit paravent des fois on n'a pas assez
de brancards donc on les gens sur des
fauteuils des fois on n'a pas assez de
couvertures ou qu'ils ont froid en fait
on n'a pas assez de place il ya une mise
en danger des patients il ya des défauts
surveillance n'a pas assez de place
notre hôpital est sous dimensionné par
rapport à notre activité
voilà je vous ai dressé un tableau un
petit peu rapide de la situation de mon
quotidien d'urgence de ce que de ce que
je viens tous les jours mais comprend
les urgences c'est aussi comprendre la
main et comprend laval comme vous ne
l'avez très bien expliqués en fait les
urgences il ya un effet domino quand ça
va pas et en fait les dominos bretons
toujours sur les urgences quand la
médecine générale est débordé ou quand
la médecine générale n'est plus
disponible aller aux urgences pour les
spécialités de ville pour les
spécialités d'hôpital aller aux urgences
le centre de soins non programmés ferry
pour les fêtes de fin d'année aller aux
urgences mais moi je suis pas sûr que
les urgences elle soit ouverte en fait
pour les fins d'année aura peut-être des
nuits fermé est on en train de se battre
pour papier de jours non plus qu'il soit
fermé je vous rappelle qu'on est quand
même hôpital support du département ont
pu tel support de j'ai acheté
il ya quelques années comme l'a très
bien dit louis soûlât en fait on
orientait en triant et les soins urgents
et maintenant en fait on prend en charge
tout le monde tout cet effet domino qui
nous retombe dessus parce qu'en fait la
lumière est allumée et on est là tout le
temps parce qu'on est les urgences en
fait est que quand on sait plus on est à
la fois et le premier recours les gens
est le dernier recours quand on sait
plus quoi faire quand on sait plus où
aller on dit aller aux urgences moi je
vis dans un département qu'il 5e m
désert médical de france ix à 6,3
médecin pour dix mille habitants il ya
10 % des plus de 16 ans qui n'ont pas de
médecin traitant donc dire aux gens bah
allez voir votre médecin traitant c'est
en fait une façon très polie de leur
dire débrouillez vous
c'est pas entendable
ça c'était pour laval
donc l'ouverture de lits mais comment
faire quand tu as pas de paramédicaux il
ya quelques années ont fermé des lits
moi j'ai une direction une ars qui ne
demandent que ça donc leur délit mais ya
pas de paramédicaux et pourquoi y en a
pas parce qu'ils sont sont dégoûtés par
ce qu'un soignante n'est pas en
technicien il faut revoir les ratios des
ratios soignants patients un soigneux
doigt un soignant doit être en forme et
en bonne santé pour prendre en charge un
patient qui par définition lui est en
détresse et actuellement nous soignons
ils sont usés et paramédicaux comme les
médecins pourquoi ils sont usés pour
plein de choses parce qu'il ya une
charge de travail des conditions de
travail une qualité de travail tout tout
les difficiles et puis il ya aussi des
petites choses qui paraissent
insignifiantes
quand tout va bien et qu'on aime son
métier et puis quand tout va mal on
regarde aussi dans le détail ce qui va
pas laisser les statuts on a déjà parlé
des ambulances il leur parle ils sont
pas reconnus comme des soignants voilà
et donc quand on a tous qui fonctionne
bien s'intéressent pas forcément à tous
et on se bat pas pour tous les combats
ou là là on cherche en fait à trouver ce
qui va bien ce qui nous motive ce qui
nous donne envie de nous lever le matin
ce qui fait qu'on a ou pas la boule au
vent pour aller au travail il ya le
ségur avec l'oubli du médico social
voilà le soin ne doit pas chercher en
premier la rentabilité
le premier médicament je le dis toujours
c'est l'humain et donc il faut remettre
de l'humain dans le soin quand vous
arrivez aux urgences vous avez envie
qu'on vous accueille avec douceur et
gentillesse et qu'on prenne en compte
votre problème est qu'on soit
humainement disponibles pourra recevoir
votre détresse est actuellement et on
n'est plus capable de le faire lundi
j'étais de garn j'ai fait plus de 25
heures de garde parce que mon bip a
sonné et quinze minutes avant la fin de
ma garde donc je suis parti en interne
je rentrais chez moi je me suis reposé
je me suis lavé j'ai mangé et et puis
après qu'est ce que j'ai fait je suis
chef de service des urgences de laval
alors j'ai fait mon travail de chef de
service j'ai fait une réunion avec mon
équipe pour préparer la certification et
puis après je suis allé à la cme j'ai
fait des réunions et en fait je n'ai pas
dormi une minute sur mon repos de carn
et c'est ça aussi que les gens pas
on
n'arrive pas à comprendre c'est que à un
moment donné on n'est plus comme
autrefois où on avait des temps of sur
les gars maintenant le flou et constants
il diminue mais il est constant la porte
est ouverte et le flux est constant les
patients arrivent tous voilà donc c'est
ça qui est difficile c'est pour ça qu'on
a du mal à enchaîner oui il ya des
années on dit oui non et hedegaard 48
heures 72 heures mais là enfin je mets
au défi n'importe qui il travaillait 48
72 c'est juste impossible
à la fin à la fin de cette année je
souhaite poser des congés comme comme
toujours depuis que je travaille donc je
suis aussi médecin généraliste jeunes et
diplômés de la camy en 2019 depuis que
je travaille je n'ai jamais eu des
conduits en entier j'ai décalé mais les
congés de deux jours au lieu d'être en
congé vendredi soir je suis en congé
dimanche et je reviendrai mercredi soir
au mieux de mes congés pour faire une
garde parce que sinon les urgences ferme
vous rendez compte de cette pression
qu'on a comporte je suis une maman de
quatre enfants et je vais leur dire en
plein milieu des vacances
dormez bien même si charline maman par
travail voilà une fois ils m'ont dit
mais il n'est pas au courant pré fille
qu'on est dimanche opté en vacances je
suis dit si mais il ya des choses qui
sont plus importantes ici mais par
l'enfant t'as fait ça fait mal donc ce
témoignage que je vous offre avec tout
mon coeur et ma sincérité c'est aussi
des témoignages que j'ai reçus d'autres
chefs de services d'établissement qui
correspondent
voilà deux villes moyennes et on partage
il y as pour moi des solutions il ya des
solutions qui existent
je suis pas
du genre à regarder ce qui ne va pas
j'aime regarder aussi ce qui va bien on
a beaucoup d'énergie on fait un métier
de passion et on est toujours force de
proposition dans les réunions on a
beaucoup d'idées mais voilà on a des
contraintes des lourdeurs
administratives des fois qu'il nous
empêche d'avancer et d'avancer vite moi
je suis urgentistes attendre une heure
c'est déjà beaucoup on quand on dit bon
on verra ça dans trois semaines ou dans
un mois ça me parlait
invraisemblable adela la notion de temps
entre un urgentiste et un administratif
c'est là on n'est pas dans le même monde
donc nous on a besoin d'avancer on a des
idées mais on veut que ça va ensuite on
a des contraintes administratives
qui nous bloque je pense et j'assume ce
que je vais dire c'est qu'il faudrait
revoir la régulation d'installation
aussi parce que c'est peut-être pas
drôle d'exercer dans un désert médical
mais c'est pas drôle dit vivre quand on
n'a pas de médecin traitant dit
il il faut revoir aussi les projets
architecturaux pour à dimensionner
correctement pour accueillir les
patients et puis y est attractif voilà
c'est important d'avoir un cadre certes
beau mais aussi adapter à la capacité
qu'on nous demande d'avoir en terme de
passage de patients et puis
valoriser nos soignants c'est à dire que
on dans le seigneur on parle d'une
infirmière de fin de carrière mais ça
n'existe plus les infirmières de fin de
carrière elle arrête avant donc il faut
stage irisé précocément les soignants il
faut valoriser dès le début des
carrières il faut favoriser tout ce qui
est innovant comme les infirmiers en
pratique avancée les délégations tâche
le sas pour moi aussi c'est une solution
et le lien envie de l'hôpital nous dans
notre établissement on avait on à la
ceni d'ordonnancement offre hospitalière
et puis on a une cellule aussi ville
hôpital mais la personne qui
devait prendre ce poste a été écoeurée
par les conditions de travail la
lourdeur la difficulté et elle est
partie donc on a en fait
plein d'idées plein de projets mais il
ya plus mais plus personne en fait pour
les mener avec les
mois je fais ce métier par passion
j'estime que je fais plus beau métier du
monde et je crois à l'hôpital public et
c'est pour ça que je me bats je
m'accroche et j'ai envie qu'on arrive
tous ensemble à amener des solutions
parce que la trop longtemps on a
considéré que la santé c'était la sphère
des soignants mais la santé c'est la
firme de tous les citoyens et
il faut vraiment s'intéresser en
profondeur et avec tous les acteurs et
tous les partenaires à la médecine de
demain et me redonner la passion les
lettres de noblesse à la santé merci
merci docteur vraiment au choix qui aura
beaucoup des changes après avec mes
collègues sur les propos vous avez tenu
d'ailleurs les uns les autres on va
terminer avec le docteur boubia
bonjour messieurs dames je vais me
présenter un oncle à vous allez voir
tout de suite très rapidement que c'est
pas du tout le même type de médecine
d'urgence qui est pratiqué sur notre
territoire mais il n'empêche que la
médecine d'urgence en termes de filières
et fondamentalement importante aussi
dans ces territoires
qui sont des territoires sous
médicalisées alors je suis le docteur
roubia jeunes présentent chef de service
des urgences du centre hospitalier de
clamecy
praticien hospitalier en médecine
d'urgence et diplômé de la faculté de
médecine de dijon
j'ai le même cursus que mes collègues
ici présents qu'ils soient professeurs
bien chef de service de grands grands
établissements je suis médecin
généraliste à la base et j'ai donc fait
une formation complémentaire capacité de
médecine d'urgence capacité béthines de
catastrophe pour pouvoir acquérir ce
statut de praticien hospitalier en
médecine d'urgence je vous dis ça entre
parenthèse parce que je considère que
c'est une grosse erreur d'avoir
supprimé la capacité de médecine
d'urgence qui avait
a une qui avait vraiment à l'intérêt
majeur d'abord quatre plus de 80 à 90%
des urgentistes en france qui sont sur
le terrain ont suivi ce cursus
ses calculs un cursus qui est qui a été
donc mis en place par les professeurs
dans le domaine hospitalier
universitaire
mais à l'heure actuelle
les urgentistes qui sont créés et même
s'ils ont une formation plus rapide
meilleur
en termes d'effectifs ils sont
infiniment moindres ça veut dire que dès
maintenant si on continue à former les
urgentistes
de cette façon là on est en train de
programmer à très court terme la pénurie
de médecins urgentistes
autres autre intérêt de la capacité de
médecine d'urgence c'est une formation
qui permettait la polyvalence ça
permettait à quelqu'un une fois qu'il a
eu sa formation de médecins urgentistes
de
pouvoir continuer à avoir le choix à
faire soit de la médecine d'urgence soit
faire de la médecine je n'ai pas de la
médecine d'urgence qui relève pas de
l'urgence donc ça favorise qu'on nous
demande paradoxalement on peut envisager
si on continue à former les gens comme
ça avec la coop stimuler l'audience
avoir des activités partagées c'est sur
quoi on doit aller on peut tout à fait
imaginer que les jeunes médecins
puissent ouvrir un cabinet sur une
maison médicale de garde avoir un
exercice de groupe parce que les jeunes
médecins il faut pas se faire
d'illusions maintenant ils veulent avoir
une activité de médecine collective en
libéral et en même temps avoir une
activité partagée à l'hôpital le système
actuel en faisant disparaître la
capacité de médecine d'urgence a
effectivement améliorer
la formation des urgentistes en créant
des urgentistes qui sont et qui ont une
formation identique au cardiologue un
pneumologue etc mais qui leur interdit
d'avoir une activité autre que de la
médecine d'urgence non seulement ils
sont moins nombreux mais en plus ils ne
peuvent pas sortir de cette espèce de
prison que représente la médecine
d'urgence
jusqu'à la fin de leur carrière et ça va
pas ça ne correspond pas à ce que
demande la société une activité partagée
hospitalière et extra hospitalières dans
le libéral bon je vais revenir à la
présentation dans l'établissement donc
donc je vous présente le territoire
sanitaires et les populations qui sont
prises en charge par le centre
hospitalier de clamecy
c'est un bassin de santé qui a plusieurs
particularités 1 il compte 25 mille
habitants sur un territoire rural
certains le qualifient même d'hyper
rurales et des géographes qui ont créé
ce concept avec des petites communes
éparpillés sur un diamètre approximatif
de 50 kilomètres à peu près il est
caractérisé ce territoire car crise et
pas par le fait qu'il est éloigné des
grands axes de circulation rapide il est
servi essentiellement par un réseau de
routes secondaires
les temps de déplacement il est dur et
de transports sanitaires sont donc plus
longue qu'ailleurs
le temps de transport estimé à partir de
clamecy donc on se trouve notre hôpital
pour faire les trajets vers les hôpitaux
de référence avoisinants sont
de 50 minutes pour le centre hospitalier
d'auxerre et de 1h10 pour le centre
hospitalier de nevers
la particulière aux sims et de la
particularité aussi importantes
qui concernent ce territoire de santé
c'est que les transports sanitaires
primaire vers les urgences de clamecy
sont essentiellement assurés ça
j'insiste là dessus par les pompiers
volontaires du territoire
donc ça ouvre une problématique qui ne
concerne pas que le système de
hospitalier 1
donc c'est eux qui assurent des
volontaires camille sur le territoire
qui assure ces transports a deux
caractéristiques concerne la sociologie
de la population du territoire une
proportion importante de retraités et
une proportion importante également de
populations socialement défavorisés ou à
faible niveau de revenu
tous présents je vous présente
maintenant l'hôpital et l'histoire
récente de l'hôpital parce qu'il faut
s'inscrire dans l'histoire récente de
l'hôpital kitty qu'ils symbolisent un
petit peu la réduction des plateaux
techniques des petites structures
c'est un hôpital de proximité qu'est le
statut d'hôpital isolé il est constitué
d'une quarantaine de lits de médecine
polyvalente à dominante gériatrique il
n'y a plus de lits d'hospitalisation
spécialisés
l'établissement est également adossé à
deux ehpad situé dans l'enceinte de
l'hôpital l'histoire récente de
l'établissement a été agité est mal vécu
par la population elle vous fait le
récapitulatif
en 2008 ça a commencé par la fermeture
de la maternité un été vécue comme un
traumatisme habituel pour ce genre de
territoire suivi de bob en 2012 par la
fermeture du service de chirurgie
générale qui a assuré la chirurgie
orthopédique et viscérale le plateau
technique chirurgicale a été transféré
vers le centre hospitalier pivot le plus
proche situé dans le département voisin
nous on est dans l'âme hier et c'est le
département voisin de l'yonne à auxerre
dans l'yonne où se trouve d'ailleurs
maintenant la direction générale de la
j'ai acheté dans nous faisons partie
pour contrebalancer cette perte de
plateau technique qu'il a été créé un
smur un service d'unités de soins
continus compte il constitué de quatre
lits sous la responsabilité des
urgentistes et un cpp un centre
périnatal de proximité pour pallier à la
fermeture de la maternité qui fonctionne
très très bien dans l'activité et
continuer à augmenter et enfin enfin
enfin l'historique récent donc en 2018
il ya eu le projet de fermeture des
urgences la nuit si
compte tenu de l'historique récent que
je vous ai décrit le territoire s'est
très fortement mobilisée avec une
médiatisation importante peut-être que
vous avez encore quelques échos
concernant les manifestations
manifestations de la population les élus
du territoire ont menacé de démissionner
collectivement les pompiers volontaires
également les entreprises même ont
exprimé leur crainte de l'ap sur la
pérennité de leur implantation locale
sachant que cale sur la ville de clamecy
on a une entreprise chimique classé
seveso
non je vous présente le service des
urgences à proprement parler donc ce ne
s'est pas uniquement l'accueil des
urgences ça déborde les urgences donc il
est ouvert 24 heures sur 24 il ya quatre
types de structures sous la
responsabilité permanente des
urgentistes un service d'accueil des
urgences constitué de cinq box dont deux
de déchocage de lits d'hospitalisation
de courte durée qui sont appelés lee
porte un smur qui couvre le territoire
le territoire donc de m6 quoi est un
service d'unités de soins continus
constitué de quatre lits permettant
d'assurer la prise en charge des
patients instables
nous assurons également la permanence
des soins
nocturne en semaine pour les patients
hospitalisés en médecine
pour réduire l' isolement de notre
établissement nous sommes dotés d'une
aire d'atterrissage nocturne j'insiste
bien là dessus nocturne
r depuis deux ans
d'un système de télémédecine d'i télé a
baissé depuis cinq ans qui a la
particularité de permettre de traiter la
phase précoce sans perte de chance les
avc sur place en collaboration immédiate
avec le chu dijon élus nv donc c'est
très rapide on a une population âgée
donc on a forcément un taux d'avc plus
important que sur sur le restant de la
population
on a aussi une biologie délocaliser
performantes disponibles en moins de 15
minutes et vous permet de balayer
largement tout ce qui relève de
l'urgence vitale et on a un scanner
opérationnel 24 heures sur 24
actuellement au niveau des effectifs
nous avons 3,3 équivalent temps plein
sur un effectif théorique de huit
équivalents temps plein
deux ph à temps plein dont je fais
partie et deux praticiens contractuels à
temps partiel pour assurer le planning
nous nous assurerons le planning en
faisant des heures supplémentaires et en
faisant appel à des vacataires des
vacataires non pas des intérimaires
insiste urgentistes régulier extérieur
afin de limiter l'intérim qui reste
exceptionnel chez nous ceux des
vacataires 1
le nombre de passages c'est entre 10 et
11 mille passages par an aux urgences je
pars pas des hospitalisations les portes
je parle pas des sorties ce mur est à
peu près 450 sorties smur je ne parle
pas des hospitalisations en us et qui
relèvent des compétences des deux
urgentistes 1 pour finir je souhaiterais
soulevé trois points problèmes aux
problématiques spécifiques à notre
établissement
on a constaté une absence d'attractivité
de notre établissement pour le
recrutement des praticiens urgentistes
et ceci depuis le début 2020
et on a aussi le report du projet depuis
2007 de la modernisation indispensable
de l'ufc et délits portent ils sont
devenus vétustes
deuxième problématique et ça c'est aussi
très important parce que ça dépasse le
cadre d'une vision purement à rs 1 la
première tic des pompiers volontaires il
ya sur la majorité des transports
primaire vers nos urgences et qui ne
peuvent se permettre d'assurer les
transports sanitaires en dehors du
secteur de peste de classement même si
je vous avais dit allez vers auxerre
c'est 50 minutes allaient vers nevers et
sont les deux établissements pivot
autour de nous c'est une heure dix un
pompier volontaire pourra le faire
exceptionnellement mais pas
régulièrement c'est clair net voilà ils
ont clairement annoncé qu'il
démissionnerait dans le cas contraire
troisième problématique là qu'on sent
parce que les plateaux techniques on
diminuait pas uniquement sûr que même si
le nom du mieux dans les hôpitaux
alentour
nous constatons la fragilisation
progressive des filières d'urgences
chirurgicales
nous avons de plus en plus de mal à
transférer nos passions surtout depuis
la fermeture de la clinique de cosne sur
loire il ya maintenant deux ans et une
clinique qui avait il y avait un contrat
de service public qu'ils étaient ouverts
24 heures sur 24 il opérait la nuit n'a
et qui constituait un établissement de
recours à 50 kilomètres de nous plaindre
si lorsque l'hôpital pivot qui est le
nôtre fait partie de la gst auxerre ne
pouvait absorber les urgences
et ça
là je peux vous donner un exemple on
avait moi c'est la première fois que je
rencontre ça dans ma vie un monsieur âgé
de plus de 90 ans qui restait dans nos
lits portes cet été avec une fracture du
col fémoral pendant quatre jours avant
d'être transféré non pas sur notre
centre pivot mais dans un hôpital encore
plus éloigné voilà donc il ya une
souffrance haut niveau il faut vraiment
raisonner en finir de soins si on veut
avoir une vision de ce que c'est que la
médecine violence c'est la filière de
soins c'est notre coeur de métier
filière de soins
et j'en terminerai par cette petite
profession de foi que vous me permettrez
j'espère 1
clamecy
petit service d'urgence
à dos et un petit hôpital
mais un service
vital sa population rurale isolée voilà
je vous remercie je suis à votre
disposition
merci docteur bout bien merci à tous les
cinq pour
le panorama vous avez d'assez qui est
dur à entendre on connaît ces réalités
vous vous les vivez au quotidien et nous
notre souci comme parlementaire c'est
d'essayer de comprendre maintenant
pourquoi la situation et celle là est
évidemment et surtout de trouver les
bons outils pour y répondre le plus
rapidement possible et notre rapporteur
catherine de roche ne va certainement
pas manquer de questions à ce sujet est
beaucoup beaucoup de questions je vais
essayer de passer à ses cours dans mes
questions
il y avait déjà des questions préparées
auquel vous avez déjà répondu je pense
que ce sera important pour nous vous
nous donner tous les éléments vous nous
est donné ce matin mais aussi peut-être
qu'il y ait des contributions écrites
mois ce qui sort un peu de vos propos c
est notamment par rapport à ce qui a été
dit par
par le docteur bruno par le docteur
boubia c'est qu'il ya quand même
des disparités territoriales y est en
effet à ce que la géographie et
l'histoire de et qu'il n'y a pas
forcément peut-être de solution unique
et d'adaptation unique
qui qui serait c'est un peu toujours ce
qu'on a voulu faire depuis longtemps dix
ans ce sera comme ça la loi ce sera ça
elle s'appliquera partout pareil je
pense qu'il va falloir qu'on réfléchisse
en effet à des solutions adaptées aux
territoires au bassin aux bassins de vie
mais aussi aux à l'organisation des
soins sur les territoires pour
fluidifier la situation ce qui me fait
peur ce qui me fait dire ça c'est par
exemple en matière de formation vous
nous avez présenté en effet ce que pour
vous le
le rôle du médecin urgentiste formation
et tout ça nous avait parlé de la
disparition des capacités j'aimerais un
peu vous parce que vous voyez réagir un
peu mais
comment vous d'un territoire à l'autre
vous vous sentez les choses et il est
vrai que à parisien comme un cochin peut
pas forcément avoir ce regard qui l'a là
bas comment vous réagissez à sable sur
le ségur le ségur et nous a été annoncé
comme une avancée indéniable avec une
revalorisation des salaires mais on voit
bien que ça n'a pas été suffisant même
si c'est important suffisant avec
notamment vous l'avez évoqué est ce
qu'on entend au fil des auditions c'est
qu'il ya comme il ya eu un peu des
disparités selon les personnels
concernés par le ségur
notamment aussi entre public privé où
les clc c'est par exemple des
difficultés
finalement ces disparités ont créé des
frustrations à mon sens et des des
formes dans vie de ce que les autres
avec certains n'ont pas elle peut-être
des envies justifier d'avoir les mêmes
choses et de fait ça annihile est
pratiquement le bénéfice est un peu de
ce qu'était le ségur en termes de
lanternes revalorisation même si ça
n'est pas suffisant
sur les images à une question pour
monsieur le chef de service de à cochin
vous nous dites on a réussi à avoir une
cellule de gestion des lits une équipe
mobile de gériatrie quelque chose qui
fonctionne bien le de tous les jours
comme ça
bon on a senti que vous étiez en effet
quelque chose qui a apporté un peu de
baume au coeur parce que ce qu'on entend
des rires quels sont les ops est ce que
la l'administration vous êtes parce que
ce qui ressort de nos auditions c'est
quand même et c'est quand même un peu à
des conséquences de la loi hpst qu'on va
évaluer c'était cette part forte de
l'administration sur le sur le le
médical est ce que vous vous avez des
obstacles de votre administration
oui ou non enfin comme on le disait et
sinon qu'est ce qui fait que ça
fonctionne bien et qu'elles sont les
rois ce qui fonctionne et qu'on pourrait
être appliqué dans d'autres dans
d'autres territoires sur le sur la
notion vous vous avez évoqué à clamecy
c'est toujours la difficulté de l'
équilibre entre la sécurité d'un
établissement
et la proximité parfois la proximité est
en effet importante pour sauver des vies
aussi parfois le fait d' établissements
qui font peu d'actes peut mettre en
péril la sécurité du patient dans 7
jours 7 et kelly brook est difficile à
trouver est-ce que vous avez
des solutions possibles sur sur ces
sujets là
est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup de patients
dans nos territoires respectifs qui
viennent directement aux urgences semble
être parce que ce mardi dont le médecin
en urgence
est-ce qu'il ya ce que roulent un peu
cette image que l'on a dû du patient qui
est pas bien qu'il ya neuf jours aux
urgences est ce que c'est une proportion
forte ou est-ce qu'elle n'existe pas à
une coopération public privé vous l'avez
évoqué je pense qu'on est fait c'est une
des pistes si on est à peu près sur les
cliniques assure un huitième des
urgences
attendez je reprends un peu les autres
questions et je vais laisser mes
collègues poser toute question
il ya eu oui la tarification vous l'avez
évoqué
la t2a avec ses limites
il ya eu des textes récents qui ont
apporté des modifications à la
tarification des urgences
est-ce que selon vous ça a été un bien
ou un mal où est ce qu'ils ont apporté
une correction on a entendu aussi un peu
le ce qu'on avait bien perçu au moment
de la loma trans les difficultés entre
en effet le secours et le soin moi je
partage ce que vous dite que j'étais
plus sur cette position que sur le texte
qui est ressorti mai mais est ce qui est
ce qu'il ya dans les les textes récents
des choses qui ont finalement aggraver
la situation plutôt calme le long
arranger parce que c'est ça maintenant
il va falloir qu'on trouve des solutions
il ya des solutions à long terme mais
des solutions à court terme on peut pas
laisser perdurer des situations que vous
décrivez à l'hôpital de laval et et même
si on dit on va informer plus de
médecins à ok mais comment on fait
revenir à l'heure dans le métier les
personnes qui en sont partis quels sont
les moyens pour faire revenir assez
rapidement des gens dans le métier dans
les circonstances actuelles voilà un peu
en vrac quelques cas merci alors je vais
vous donner la parole à tous les 5 vous
répondez à cela pas vous souhaitez
répondre un voilà c'est tout à fait tout
à fait libre donc on va refaire on va
repartir dans le sens inverse pour le
tour de table si vous voulez bien
docteur boubia vous avez des éléments
rapportés aux questions là à porter donc
j'ai déjà partiellement répondu à votre
question en vous parlant justement de de
la problématique de la formation
quantitativement des deux urgentistes je
pense que personnellement si les salles
engage que moi considèrent que c'est une
erreur d'avoir abandonné la capacité de
médecine d'urgence
perte de 2,2 de perdre quantitativement
de d'urgentistes avec une formation qui
était solide 1 qui était d'ailleurs
effectué par nos professeurs hospitalo
universitaires voilà donc là on perd
allez on va dire à la louche sur mon
père 70% des effectifs de deux futurs
médecins urgentistes 1 mais en même
temps on perd cette polyvalence conte
avec la capacit médecine d'urgence donc
je pense que sur un point de vue
purement pragmatique ça serait rétabli
recettes d'outils de double filière de
si on va être pragmatique un set 12
filières de formation et permettre donc
ça permettrait aussi d'améliorer
l'attractivité de la médecine d'urgence
en permettant des activités partagées on
peut imaginer des jeunes générations
travaillant dans une maison de santé la
moitié du temps et l'autre moitié du
temps à l'hôpital donc ça aurait aussi
l'avantagé de fluidifier justement et de
renforcer ce lien médecine de ville
médecine hospitalière en décloisonnant
cette activité ça serait vraiment
l'idéal voilà il aurait une double
expertise ces jeunes médecins
ça je pense que c'est si on veut être
efficace
rapide s'il faut mettre le paquet
là-dessus rétablir la capacité des
médecins d'urgence et rendre la
possibilité un médecin de faire soit de
la médecine d'urgence soit les médecines
libéral soit les deux et en fonction de
l'évolution dans sa vie on peut imaginer
qu'il se retire la médecine d'urgence et
faire que du numéraire et ça on a perdu
un outil qui était quand même
remarquablement efficace quoi
sinon les tracasseries administratives
avec les différentes les différentes
directions des hôpitaux en coller tout
ça est un turnover important nous on a
le on a quelques camps dirais-je on a on
a le le le savoir-faire des soignants on
a l'expertisé du soignant vous savez
bien qu'au niveau de la gouvernance on a
pas mal
donc ça ça ne c'est une c'est une c'est
malheureusement quand je vois qu'il ya
des des quantités énormes de professeur
d'université sur la psp qui est
considéré comme l'aristocratie du
système hospitalier français qui se sont
mis à aa critique ça s'était jamais vu
qu'ils se sont mis à démissionner ça
s'était jamais vu dans l'histoire de 2,2
du système hospitalier français
c'est qu'il ya vraiment un malaise c'est
vraiment les derniers à démissionner et
à faire grève c'est une grève sur le
papier parce qu'ils sont réquisitionnés
donc tout ça ça devrait en quelque sorte
permettre à nos représentants élus
démocratiquement de faire bouger les
choses en tenant compte de notre
expérience de terrain
le dire c'est nous qui soignons c'est
nous qui prenons en charge les patients
c'est nous qui voyons les carences c'est
nous qui voyons en termes de filières de
soi la différence la différence la prise
en charge d'une urgence à cochin au chu
de rennes dans un secteur
libéral mais un secteur libéral dans une
grande métropole toulouse
et engendrera donc tout ça si le mérite
aussi de la médecine d'urgence de
s'adapter à chacune des configurations
ne peut pas dire bon aujourd'hui avoir
un quota de 10 patients et on s'arrête
parce que nos vies sont plaints non ça
fonctionne pas comme ça mais c'est une
urgence
on peut pas enlever l'infarctus je le
prends en charge
à cochin ils ont la salle de coraux il
pousse un muret dans la salle de coraux
moi je prends en charge d'infarctus il
arrive sur ses pigeons prochain mon
service je commence à le traiter et
j'attends une heure à peu près avant de
le transférer
vers l'hôpital pivot d'auxerre où se
trouve la salle coronarographie tout ça
c'est une question de filières de soins
si on ne raisonne pas en filière de
soins avec les spécificités des filières
de soins on multipliera les exemples à
l'infini et voilà qu'est ce qui se passe
avec la filière de soins est question
des grades à ce que ces dégrade pas
est-ce qu'on peut l'améliorer
comment est-ce qu'on améliore il faut
toujours raisonner en filière de soins
sinon on est à côté
est ce ce que pouvait lire merci dr
vraiment
on la première chose c'est assumer les
difficultés
location et les difficultés cela veut
dire reconnaître qu'on est en difficulté
au niveau de l'hôpital et du système de
santé parce qu'on peut pas traiter un
problème s'il n'existe pas et ce qui est
difficile dans l'hôpital c'est d'avoir
la possibilité de parler on a toujours
peur que si on dit que ça va pas eh ben
on va être délétère au niveau de la
traite l'attractivité et que les gens
vont pas avoir envie de venir dans notre
hôpital parce qu'on met en avant ce qui
va pas donc il faut dire ce qui ne va
pas pour pouvoir
faire un état des lieux le comprendre le
cône est maîtrisé ce qui ne va pas et
ensuite penser l'amélioration et ça déjà
c'est la bahn est ce que c'est ce qui
est en train de se produire actuellement
et c'est assez inédit et je pense que
c'est une bonne chose parce que ça va
mal partout et on le voit enfin les
langues se délient les gens parlent et
ça c'est une bonne chose on va remettre
à plat tout après il ya plein de choses
qui vont bien et j'en suis ravi mais là
on est là pour parler de de ce qui ne va
pas et ça c'est vraiment un premier pas
est la grosse difficulté qu'on peut
avoir avec nos administrations et de
noailles reste c'est qu'ils ont peur ils
ont peur de dire ce qui ne va pas la
deuxième chose que pour comment faire
revenir notre des soignants
c'est
compliqué parce que maintenant non
seulement ils s'en vont en plus ils
finissent même pas leurs études cette
année on avait vraiment des écoles
d'infirmiers et infirmières il y avait
30 % jusqu'à 300 d'étudiants qui
finissait pas leur cursus donc il faut
des messages forts sur les statuts et je
pense qu'il faut vraiment
faire un autre ségur où on lis les
différences de statuts et je pense que
ça ça va être des messages politiques
très très forts qui peuvent redonner
confiance il faut qu'ils aient une
homogénéité dans la façon dont on traite
le travail supplémentaire
en fonction des drh qu'on a on peut soit
mettre sur un compte épargne temps soit
un raid sur avoir des heures
supplémentaires mais on peut pas choisir
alors un coup on choisit un conte
choisit pas fins et des négociations qui
sont usantes il ya même dans mon hôpital
en situations où en fonction du service
où vous allez faire vos heures sur vous
est majoré ou pas de 50% donc on se
retrouve à faire un avoir un système
aberrant où on a des soignants de
réanimation qui vont aller faire les
leurs a reçus pour nous n'était que vide
mais pas en réa parce que leur les
heures sup elles sont mieux payés en
unités provident sauf quand et n'importe
qu'elle soigne on peut pas les rangs
l'animation donc ces aberrations là
qu'il faut
arrêter stopper parce que elles sont les
toxiques au plus profond pour l'hôpital
et
si on à ses ennemis tout simple et quand
on donne des messages forts pour
retravailler sur les statuts ont les
ambulanciers les iaaf voilà tout laisse
tous les soignants imprimé au niveau
médical je pense que ça redonnera la
confiance parce qu'il faut de la
confiance on a un métier de passion en
une fois je monte dans un avion il a le
pilote avons qu'on discute un petit peu
montrer à mes enfants voilà le cockpit
il me dira vous êtes urgentistes il a
une idée
mais c'est un métier de passion aux
infirmières ça fait rêver les enfants
médecins ça fait rêver les enfants comme
pompier comme vétérinaire voilà donc
normalement on devrait recruter et en
fait on on casse les vocations donc il
faut arrêter ça et ensuite
je parlerai de l'éducation de la
population
non depuis quelques semaines on
travaille un petit peu plus fort sur
l'éducation de la population a rabâché
dans les médias sur les panneaux
publicitaires avant de vous rendre aux
urgences appelez votre médecin traitant
faites le 15 fait le 116 117 et on a
constaté que ça fonctionnait un petit
peu mais il faut avoir un message qu'ils
soient répétitif fort et il faudrait un
message vraiment nationale d'autres
aspects de la loi a fait de belles
affichent une belle campagne qu'on
relais et on s'est rendu compte que les
gens avaient avec la médiatisation une
petite prise de conscience à dire on va
peut-être pas aller aux urgences
directement ils nous appellent et
qu'est-ce que je peux faire est donc la
solution c'est urgemment le sas parce
qu'en fait
avoir une solution à proposer dans la
journée nous on a la chance en mayenne
et c'est ce qui m'a fait venir dans ce
département d'avoir une permanence des
sens qui fonctionne c'est à dire que à
20 heures le médecin libéral qui prend
la régulation il a eu huit effecteur sur
le sur le département ça fonctionne 24
heures sur 24 les week-ends et jours
fériés et même les pauvres ça veut dire
qu'un généraliste il peut fermer sa
porte le week-end et la nuit sans avoir
l'impression d'abandonner ses passions
et ça c'est confortable et semoy c'est
ce qui m'a fait venir en mayenne je suis
tourangelle
à la base et donc le sas va nous aider
va nous sauver parce que c'est ce qui va
permettre de proposer
aux patients une solution à court terme
et je pense aussi de se créer des
structures salariés parce que la
lourdeur administrative peu effrayés
aussi
à l'installation de jeunes médecins mais
je pense que vous aviez raison c'est
se diversifier dans la carte de ce qu'on
va proposer comme solution parce qu'un
territoire ne ressent pas un autre la
spécificité d'un désert médical
nécessite qu'on prenne des mesures un
petit peu différente et il faut
reconnaître la spécificité de chacun y à
paris il ya les grandes villes il y a
les villes moyennes et il ya les déserts
médicaux
merci dr oscar
alors je reviens sur ce que disait
docteur boubia effectivement c'est
l'effet contre-productif désastreux du
de la spécialité de médecine d'urgence
sûrs strictes qui enferme les titulaires
de la qualité de la qualification dans
une activité n'est est un exercice
univoque dont ils ne peuvent sortir j'en
veux pour exemple donc le suis moi même
un généraliste titulaire de la gamme eu
on essaye depuis quelques mois de créer
un centre de consultations non
programmées
dans une cité dortoir là à côté de
toulouse colomiers
on très bien on feint d'être occupé la
mairie nous a ouvert les bras tout le
monde était content les médecins
généralistes ou indépendants on a fait
une demande au conseil départemental de
l'ordre des médecins et la non vous
n'êtes plus généraliste parce que vous
exercez le rincer résurgence
mais je suis médecin généraliste non ça
fait trois ans le président en question
que je connais depuis 50 ans à 10,2 ça
fait trois ans que tu n'as pas exercer
la médecine générale parce que tu es
dans un service d'urgence donc il faut
que tu fasses un stage
de 30 au bourg chez un médecin
généraliste pour ce que je fais tous les
jours
fatiguant on essaye quand même de faire
des trucs mais comme voilà dans le doute
comme on pourrait peut-être y arriver on
nous fout des bâtons dans les roues
c'est épuisant voilà pour cette histoire
de tarification alors pour les hôpitaux
et le prix et le puy le privé d'ailleurs
cette t2a qui ne nous concerne nous
gentis libéraux pas réellement à part en
termes d'investissements de la part de
l'établissement mais concernant notre
rémunération à nous il ya une réforme
qui est en train de s'appliquer qui est
normalement doit s'appliquer au 1er
janvier 2022 alors l'ancien système ont
fonctionné comme nos confrères
généralistes et spécialistes de ville
avec une
nomenclature la ngp et la ccm
la médecine d'urgence avait été à
l'époque totalement oubliés du système
donc on a pioché un petit peu partout il
y avait une sorte de cote mal taillée
mais bon s'ils étaient habitués et ça
fonctionnait avec quelques aberrations à
savoir que l'extraction d'un corps
étranger dans l'oeil était mieux
rémunérés que la prise en charge d'un
infarctus du myocarde
ce qui était un petit peu bizarroïdes et
on nous a sorti un nouveau système avec
des forces et en fonction de l'âge etc
qui aboutit après calcul sur l'ensemble
des confrères avec un une rémunération
qui à la fin de l'année oscille entre
eux plus 15 et moins 15% selon
l'activité et les établissements je ne
vous cache pas que mes confrères qui
devront arriver à moins 15 je suis pas
sûr qu'ils continuent à exercer ce
métier parce que c'est pas tenable
financièrement parlant puisque les
urssaf et là car le feu ne prennent pas
en compte le rond de choses avec ce
décalage dans le temps est de -1 et -2
en termes de chat là c'est impossible et
lorsqu'on discute depuis plusieurs mois
avec la dg os et c'est censé s'appliquer
au 1er janvier 2022 on a eu d'ailleurs
des retours de la caisse primaire du 93
qui annonce que duché d'une
impréparation technique il annonce qu'il
n'y aura pas de rémunération pour les
urgentistes libéraux en janvier et en
février
il envisage peut-être de démarrer le
système au mois de mars mais c'est pas
sûr
g
formation il paraît qu'au nom la caisse
nationale a dit pas du tout sauf qu'il
ya une caisse nationale d'assurance pas
eddy appris à s'en séparer chaque cepam
et indépendante et là on retombe sur ce
travers
administratif un petit peu fou auquel
nous ne comprenons rien on n'y a pas
accès mais s'il va se passer ça va être
un drame et les services qu'ils vont
faire mais il ya des gens qui vont
le camp
c'est que locaux du lieu du stage
visiblement c'est une spécificité dans
le 31
mai le président du conseil
départemental de l'eau en t1
et dont ils font ils ont fait ils ont
utilisé un texte qui a été utilisée
initialement pour les praticiennes qui
avait pour des raisons de longue maladie
de congé de maternité aider le peu de
gens qui n'ont pas travaillé pendant
plus de trois ans
au gouvernement insuffisance
professionnelle
comme quoi la proche d'euros cratique
n'appartient pas qu'à l'état
de la culture
et c'est un grand président de leur
classe avec lui poser depuis cinq ans
merci si la confraternité était la
solution à ces problèmes soient ses
présidents malgré qu'ils entendent le
chef
des normes nationales m'a fait une
réponse dans ce sens
j'ai posé la question dr demain
je vais être un petit peu à 30 contre
courant de ce qui a été dit là jusqu'à
présent
pour ce qui concerne déjà la spécialité
de médecine d'urgence alors que je suis
généraliste encore une fois je le
revendique cap estienne décide urgent je
pense que c'est la meilleure des choses
qui soit arrivée notre spécialité moi je
suis un vieux pour voir comment les gens
gentils c'était considéré par le monde
hospitalier auparavant d'être très
claires on n'allait pas aux urgences on
ne faisait pas la carrière que j'étais
externe mais n'avait pas le label la
médecine d'urgence et services d'urgence
étaient sous la responsabilité soit dur
un animateur médicale lemire soit la
médecine interne et on y envoyaient les
médecins qui n'avaient aucune aucun
avenir hospitaliers ont dit tiens c'est
pas de cause pour toi danse bon j j'ai
pas de place pour toi en médecine en
spécialité donc va donc aux urgences on
avait des gens qui ont fait un peu de la
médecine d'urgence par obligation et bon
nombre de médecins particulièrement des
médecins à diplôme étranger sont arrivés
aux urgences par ces raisons là
là enfin on a une formation on a une
reconnaissance au moins j'allais dire
administrative qui permet donc de
discuter d'égal à égal avec d'autres
spécialités nous sommes au même rang que
les autres bien évidemment il faut
prévoir des passerelles j'entends très
bien je pense que l'importance de dire
qu'on est une spécialité on a discuté
avec lui et parfois on n'est pas
d'accord sur certaines orientations et
de dire qu' on est une spécialité pas à
part entière on est une vraie spécialité
c'est fondamental dans les discussions
qu'on peut avoir avec nos collègues à
l'hôpital ça a changé radicalement les
choses vous parliez tout à l'heure des
professeurs sait plus qui paraît des
professeurs qui signent des démissions
ou qui signent des tribunes dans des
journaux dans des quotidiens encore une
fois méfiance méfiance aussi sur
beaucoup de choses d'accord moi je
venais j'en ai assez ai plus qu'assez
que des médecins qui ne sont pas de
notre spécialité se permettre d'aller
prendre la parole sur des plateaux télé
dans des journaux pour dire voilà ce qui
ne va pas aux urgences je trouve que ça
ça nous dessert et que ces personnes-là
voit déjà dans leur spécialité les
difficultés qui demeurent là tout ça
pour dire quoi pour dire que je pense
que votre exemple votre ce que vous
venez dire est aussi un bon exemple il
n'ya pas l'ennemi n'est pas que
l'administration
où l'animation n'est pas qu'un ennemi
c'est faux vous posez la question tout à
l'heure de dire est ce que j'avais des
prêts avec mon administration et oui
elle m'aide mais ce n'est pas à
l'administration ce sont les personnes
qui représente l'administration
vous d'expliquer que c'est un médecin
conseil de l'ordre qui vous demande
d'aller refaire des plâtres enfin je
veux dire c'est juste hallucinant il a
on n'est pas sur le plan administratif
on est sur le plan simplement de
confraternité donc voilà où pour
répondre à votre question d'ailleurs
madame oui j'ai la chance d'avoir
peut-être et j'ai peut-être je suis
peut-être né avec une
cuillère d'argent c'est possible ou une
bonne étoile je n'en sais rien en tout
état de cause j'ai la chance de d'avoir
une administration locale à la paix qui
est parfaitement dans l' écoute et qui
est conforme encore une fois qu'il est
temps qu'a passé de me dire non mais
d'expliquer le pourquoi du comment
l'abbé à une organisation très
pyramidale et bien même le sommet de la
paix on peut discuter je suis désolé
j'arrive à discuter je ne dis pas qu on
obtient tout laissé dans loin de là mais
on peut discuter et je moi je me bats
pour dire on arrête de diocèse comme
andy l'hôpital de laval il est pas bon
parce que je suis allé une fois dans le
service machin il est pas bon faut
arrêter de dire ça c'est une mauvaise
expérience qu'on a c'est un individu
qu'on a rencontrés qui s'est mal passé
arrêtons de stigmatiser
parce que s'esquisse à qui hantera aussi
de nous tuer au niveau de l'hôpital
on stigmatise ces l'administration
contre le professeur contre le ph le ph
console professeurs et c'est tout et ça
ça nous ça nous fait mal à un mal fou
vous disiez tout à l'heure il faut aussi
arrêter de dire que tout va bien en tout
cas pas se passer avant tout cas de
montrer les choses qui vont mal on n'est
pas la même génération
profitez-en on n'est pas de la même
génération mais ça fait des années que
les urgences vont mal d années et des
années et des années depuis que je suis
externe les gens sont là et finalement
les urgences ont été simplement un avant
coureur de ce que ce qui est devenu
l'hôpital donc que les hellal les
politiques vous en êtes responsable
vous en êtes responsable parce que vous
n'avez pas entendu
les messages peut-être pas forcément
toujours très bien très bien écrit mais
c'est possible mais en tout cas vous ne
l'avez pas entendu et donc on a voulu on
a laissé les choses évoluent
progressivement esaü évidemment un effet
domino sur l'hôpital aussi vous
expliquer tout à l'heure monsieur vous
bien que dans votre service dans votre
hôpital vous faites si ça ça et c'est un
atout il ya un moment l'urgentiste doit
être en capacité de dire non je ne fais
pas nous avons des missions l'émission
elles nous sont
données sur le plan réglementaire et
nous ne sommes pas là pour pallier à
tous les dysfonctionnements de l'hôpital
je parlais par exemple de lagarde dit
d'intérieur si vous devez aller faire la
guerre à l'est pas et c'est tout il y à
des baies les médecins qui travaillent
je pense qu'aussi il faut être en
capacité de dire non on doit dire non
aussi si on dit non quand dire non ça
veut pas dire non débrouille et vous
c'est pas ça je dis je dis simplement on
dit non maintenant organiser vous vous
les autres spécialités aussi fait aussi
d'autres choses qu'on ait une discussion
c'est ça que je veux dire cette
discussion et doit être générale si on
prend le problème des urgences
uniquement les difficultés qu'on a un
urgent ans je parle pas de la carrière
je pense pas que tout ça c'est pas de la
difficulté du travail si on ne parle qu
aux urgences on va nous donner peut-être
qu'ils un brancard par 600 euros de plus
dans la journée et c'est tout et c'est
pas ça qui fera changer il faut pas
considérer l'ensemble de la difficulté
de l'hôpital encore une fois arrêtons de
nous voiler la face c'est aussi en
interne dans l'hôpital par manque de
moyens on est très clair aussi dans les
autres spécialités vous donne un exemple
le plan 0 brancard qui a lieu d'accord
c'est un plan qui est donné en tout cas
au moins au niveau des sciences lui
aussi de diminuer les brancards
dans mon hôpital tout ce qui a été mis
en place ne concerne pas directement
l'activité des urgences on parle de
filières de soins on a embauché une
assistante sociale pour les bêtes
bloqueurs on a tout ça en discutant avec
l'administration les nuits d'accord avec
l'administration
avec aussi d'autres collègues de
l'hôpital donc on n'a pas cet argent
j'ai refusé et puis ce qu'est ce que
font la plupart maintenant des médecins
aujourd'hui ne lancez pas pour nous
c'est pas au niveau des urgences qu'il
faut c'est en aval l'attractivité
le numerus clausus a diminué de manière
catastrophique on le sait tout sur le
plan médical depuis des années mais
notre spécialité n'est pas la seule la
cdpa l'assaut dans la difficulté partout
la psychiatrie je sors d'une réunion
tout à l'heure où la psychiatrie
qu'étant une spécialité mais dans un
état catastrophique
on va arrêter sur cochin par exemple à 2
milliards de psychiatrie par manque me
dit-on d'effectifs psychiatrique sur
l'ensemble du g h avec aussi un autre
hôpital avec qui on travaille donc la
difficulté elle et il faut essayer en
effet 2 n'aura pas plutôt pardon de
solution miracle tant que nos étudiants
soient formés et arrive après ça va
prendre du temps donc pour relancer
l'attractivité de nos services d'urgence
redonnons non pas d'attractivité hausse
à dos les hôpitaux mais en tout cas
organisons différemment et mettons aussi
tout le monde autour de la table et
allons voir les véritables problèmes
aussi qui existent dans tous les
services je pense que c'est toutes les
spécialités ensemble qu'on arrivera à
modifier les choses
merci avant de donner la parole au
professeur soulage voudrais que vous
poursuiviez une réponse à la nôtre à
porter à catherine de roche parce
qu'elle vous a interrogé sur les textes
récents qui ont été adoptés vous êtes
ici au parlement devant une commission d
enquête parlementaire et vous avez un
peu interpellé le monde politique en
disant en nous disant mais au fond si on
en est là c'est pas nouveau et vous
n'avez pas pris les bonnes décisions de
mémoire moi je suis parlementaire depuis
quatre ans ces récents mais on a adopté
sur les urgences un certain nombre de
dispositions le forfait réorientation
pour dire allez hop on valaisan bon
les sites juste et justement je joue on
voudrait catherine deneuve a interrogé
quand même là dessus ben sahar quel est
votre regard génère le forfait
orientation le forfait patients urgence
une modification du financement qui
introduit notamment une dotation
populationnelle
oui et avec ya la dotation
populationnelle et des critères de
qualité et c est la quatrième
disposition c'était le sas de mémoire
c'est à peu près le travail législatif
de ces dernières années sur les urgences
c'est
mais ce qu'ils étaient tu es au
parlement il me semble ce sont ces
points là ces dernières années c'est
quoi votre regard sur ces dispositions
alors le forfait de réorientation
je l'avais expliqué une réunion avec
l'époque c'était au tout début des eaux
tout début les ars pour réorienter
quelqu'un il faut l'examiner une fois
que vous l'avez examiner et souvent le
diagnostic ou leaf est une horde aux
îles sans voix le problème est réglé
avec le système du forfait de
réorientation
il faut deux voire trois personnes pour
gérer un problème concret ne résout pas
le problème et ça induit accessoirement
un sentiment qu parcours à nos confrères
généralistes
c'est à dire que le patient va aller à
l'hôpital va être réorientée l'hôpital
père soit 60 euros ont des histoires de
structure et cd rom et que ne comprend
pas le médecin généraliste en ville et
lui va gagner 25 euros pour faire le
boulot à passe par
ses patrons pas du tout
les forfaits les forfaits aux urgences
et il est reportée dans son application
par dont il a été adopté mais toujours
pas où il est censé être appliquée au
1er janvier
est reportée oui pas fait c'est donc un
jour avec l'évaluer on va être honnête
plus 15 - gaz ou comme je voulais et à
l'heure ça va ça va être désagréable
parce que la réorientation je partage
pas du tout cet avis là c'est à dire que
encore une fois là rien notation n'est
pas une réorientation médical et les
fêtes par l'infirmière d'accueil et de
rien et d'orientation est justement moi
je trouvais tout à fait aberrant que
alors qu'il ya
une prise de constantes une décision
prise par un personnel de santé que
celles ci avant que pour réorienter le
patient ça se faisait bien avant que
pour voir on va pas attendre le 1er
janvier 2022 pour le faire dans certains
endroits et bien en tout cas on perdait
fréquemment d'argent et en plus en terme
de valorisation de l'acte infirmiers
liés aux qui est un poste clé dans les
services d'urgences balader dans pas mal
de services d'urgence en france il ya
plein de services d'urgence ou le tri
n'est pas fait correctement par manque
de personnel infirmier il n'ya pas diao
qui est dédié en permanence là dessus et
ça c'est inadmissible et ça c'est une
perte de chance pour le malade très
clairement et là véritablement
l'administration locale un rôle
fondamental là dessus quand je vois que
des infirmiers font aussi bien en
journée ou en nuit par contre surtout la
nuit aussi bien là que yao que le soin
voire même dans l'air thrombolyse ont
débloqué pour la télétransmission en une
heure et demie avec le service de du chu
qui va vous aider à faire quelque chose
c'est juste pas possible donc sous
trouve ça que c'est une excellente chose
ça c'est pas le problème maintenant la
question c'est comme disait le club remo
c'est quand on dit allez voir votre
médecin généraliste
s'est gentiment mais où on voit ton le
patient moi ça ne me dérange pas de
faire de la régulation de faire de la de
réorienter comme vous le dites ce qu'on
va réorienter ses des patients qui en
est fait en deux minutes on peut
simplement les voir faire le diagnostic
et les faire sortir on va les renvoyer
très bien pas de souci tout le monde s'y
retrouve le généraliste el généralistes
en tout cas le médecin de qui fait de la
médecine d'urgence ou du soins non
programmés qui va s'installer à côté de
votre hôpital on le voit à paris on a
des structures privées qui font de
l'urgence médicale qui s'installe
dès qu'ils font des cabinets d'accord ou
ces cabinets où ils sont prêts à
recevoir les patients ou 7 engine ils
vont l'avoir en quelques minutes ils ne
vont pas faire comme nous d'ailleurs de
prévention autre chose que peut faire le
médecin généraliste qui est dans son
rôle aussi en même temps qu'il fait
langil il à faire de la prévention et
discuter d'autre chose et on va chercher
quelque chose de particulier et donc on
peut la voir encore faut-il que ces
personnes là existent moi la seule chose
qui me gêne un petit peu c'est d'après
ce que j'ai compris c'est les
modifications en tout cas des
tarifications des pièces qu'on peut
faire aux urgences va un peu à
l'encontre de ce qu'on nous apprend nous
en médecine d'urgence c'est-à-dire de
faire le bon élève en examen pour le bon
patient et non pas dans le cas du médico
légal je pense qu'il faut arrêter ça
mais de faire des basses et des examens
et on va nous en nous en plein c'est
très fort à faire plus d'examens
complémentaires à faire plus de choses
qui font que nos patients vont rester
plus longtemps parce que les services
ressources biologie imagerie sont à
l'agonie dans nos hôpitaux
professeur soula et puis après mes
collègues ont encore des questions à
vous poser
sur les réformes vous avez cité moi je
suis un fervent défenseur de la
réorientation parce que ça fonctionne la
difficulté c'est bien sûr trouver
défection dès lors qu on réoriente
pourquoi il faut le mettre en place
parce qu'on peut pas d'un côté se
plaindre de ne pas maîtriser l'amant et
de papous et pas pouvoir limiter l'accès
aux urgences à ses patients comptera
orienté et je fais le lien tout
simplement avec le saas le sas c'est
exactement ça c'est que notre objectif
c'est d'éduquer la population à appeler
un numéro santé ne pas aller aux
urgences en passer par ce numéro et on
applique les mêmes principes de
réorientation au niveau de l'accueil des
urgences que qu'au niveau 2 au niveau du
samu donc il ya une logique qui est
logique alors certes je rappelle quand
même que ces infirmières essai validé
par un médecin référent l'accueil quand
même c'est sûr c'est presque plus lourd
que de voir le patient mais n'empêche
qu'on peut pas d'un côté nous accuser
d'avoir capté des patients comme c'est
fait souvent des patients de thiès
général dès lors depuis 2002 parce que
le problème il est que depuis 2002 une
extension d'activité des 15 et des samu
qu'on nous reproche parce qu'on a capté
ces patients et la tarification à
l'activité est un peu notre carottes 110
ans et plus vous ferez de consultations
d'urgence puis vous aurez de financement
donc cette réforme de la réorientation c
bien et je fais le lien avec celle du
financement qui repose sur des critères
populationnelle de type de patients
qu'on prend en charge et ceux des
critères qualité elle nous semble alors
il ya eu des modélisations qui ont été
faites y en a qui vont être des gagnants
en a qui vont être perdants mais nous
semble plus honnête par rapport à ce que
l'on fait vraiment dans les urgences et
pour nous il nous semble nécessaire et
et cohérente donc elle n'est pas elle
n'est pas complètement mises en place on
a des modélisations je sais que pour la
région bretagne par exemple ces deux
millions si ce qu'on peut espérer en
plus mais ça permet de s'adapter à la
diversité de nos services d'urgence
parce qu'on a des services d'urgence ou
les parisiens où il ya 15% de deux
d'hospitalisation et donc de financement
des consultations est important il yad
autres hôpitaux comme je pense laval et
rennes on a 30 35 40 % d'hospitalisation
a pas le passage aux urgences c'est pas
les mêmes patients donc cette
notification
elle est intéressante mais à l'ap encore
été mise en place par contre oui le sas
le sas c'est important parce que c'est
ce qui doit nous permettre de contrôler
l'accès aux soins d urgence et on espère
moeurs et orienter le patient je
rappelle juste que le concept du sas
c'est de replacer le médecin du traitant
au coeur du parcours du patient et ça il
faut pas l'oublier sais c'est pas une
volonté de l'hôpital avec son ca but de
récupérer des appels c'est surtout de
faire en sorte que le médecin traitant
soit le premier au coeur du parcours
passion après je vais revenir un peu sur
la formation je pense qu'il ya une
erreur qui il ne faut pas faire c'est
confondre formation de la décharge
dentiste et organisation des services
d'urgence la médecine d'urgence elle est
aujourd'hui une spécialité elle a été
voulue elle est reconnue elle est
choisie par les jeunes médecins pourquoi
est ce qu'elle est venue très complète
maintenant on fait de l'échographie
entre espitalier ont fait les
échographies aux urgences et cette
formation là mais il faut un certain
niveau qui rentre dans le cadre de
l'équivalence des autres spécialités par
contre la médecine d'urgence dans la
pratique il ya deux principes
incontournables qu'il faut respecter
c'est celui de la proximité il faut être
capable d'apporter des soins d'urgence
de proximité et et des filières de soins
les patients qu'on voit en urgence
notamment les ce qu'on appelle et ccnucc
a tous émus 5 qui sont les patients les
plus graves ce sont les mêmes partout
sur tout le territoire la seule
différence c'est que
la périodicité n'est pas la même on
verra certainement plus d'infarctus à
laval
clamecy et donc il faut que les niveaux
technicité pour nous sur gentil ce qui
ce mal même et donc il faut un niveau de
formation qui soit élevé je regrette il
faut il faut c'est un travail qui était
longue haleine je pense que il faut pas
prendre et nous un travail
d'arrière-garde on a tous été formés sur
terre en pratique et ça c'est fini on
doit plus être formés comme on a été
formé dix matches qu'on peut donner sur
une autre formation aux jeunes
aujourd'hui s'est passé là par contre là
où je vous rejoins complètement c'est
que l'organisation des services là doit
être intelligente aujourd'hui dans un
service d'urgence il est tout à fait
possible d'avoir des médecins
généralistes ils font souvent la
médecine polyvalente et d'avoir des
médecins urgentistes soi même d'avoir
des médecins gériatres 2005 c'est à dire
ça c'est l'organisation des services de
chance qu'il nous faut mettre en place
deuxième chose sur l'organisation des
services d'urgence pour peu on puisse
répondre à ce besoin de proximité je
voulais dit je pense qu'il faut
s'interroger aujourd'hui sur le nombre
de services d'urgence qui sont ouverts h
24 et ça c'est la réforme des
autorisations et des voir si on n'a pas
intérêt à organiser les soins d'urgence
de proximité en maintenant les smur en
priorité parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'hôpitaux je sais pas à terme si comme
moi vous avez digne de garde aux
urgences parce que il y en a une ou 2 2
vous avez deux lignes de garde pour
combien de passage
et se met ensuite et de sortie ce mur
voilà donc la vraie question c'est qu'il
faut se poser et non mais je sais tout
problème c'est que effectivement vous
annoncer quand même deux lignes de gains
avec une activité qui est limité et par
contre aujourd'hui on a vraiment intérêt
à partager la pénibilité des services à
maintenir un niveau de technicité
important il faut que les urgentistes
août sur des sites en priorisant les
choses et je suis pas sûr aujourd'hui
qui file ses vertus et même si sa prose
est plein de transports à maintenir des
structures d'urgence aux épées sage
parle à titre personnel donc c'est que
les choses qui à mon avis il faudra
apprendre à les organiser sion pour que
la pénibilité je prends l'exemple de
laval que je suis allée audités avec un
collègue danger vous avez combien de
structures d'urgence périphériques autre
que laval 2-2 qui ont deux lignes de
garde complète on ferme des urgences
dans le chef lieu alors qu'autour on a
deux fois deux lignes de garde
d'urgentistes sur les deux autres sites
bon il faut se poser des questions
pourquoi on en est là parce que la
pénibilité n'est pas la même
certainement et qu'on n'a pas réussi à
faire ce qu'on essaye de faire c'est
cette uniformité prise en charge sur un
territoire
si
il faut être assez vigilant je partage
le propos mais il faut aussi que
l'hôpital qui resteraient ouverts et
soit dimensionné pour pour accueillir
parce que moi les les urgences qui sont
à côté les deux hôpitaux d'à côté ces
îles sont pas ils sont à
24000 passage donc c'est qu'ils sont pas
petit non plus donc il faut être
vigilant aussi à ça est pas allé un peu
trop vite on s'en va on garde on garde
un service d'urgence ouverts la nuit et
et il faut voir aussi les partenariats
c'est assez complexe en terme de
territoire
et c'est très compliqué aussi enfin
enfin nous pendre déjà beaucoup de gens
qui sont déjà à temps partagé sur
d'autres hôpitaux donc six étaient
fermés danis et aller ailleurs donc les
distances c'est en termes de de qualité
de vie d'attractivité le
le changement sera complexe et
politiquement c'est aussi très difficile
donc c'est quelque chose qui est
vraiment nécessite du temps et de la
préparation au niveau du terrain et
c'est vrai que c'est assez
incompréhensible que un chef lieu de
département ferme ses urgences alors que
les hôpitaux plus petits restent ouverts
mais d'un autre côté quand on est à
mayenne il draine aussi beaucoup de
passagers aoc il ya une désertification
médicale au niveau des urgences autour
de l'hôpital de mayenne sur les régions
qui sont alentours donc la difficulté
c'est que non seulement ces pays de la
loire mais c'est aussi la bretagne la
normandie et le centre hospitalier du
nord mayenne
reçoit des patients
parce que vitré ferme et frau cher enfin
donc c'est au carrefour de trois régions
que c'est complexe et on peut pas
je dis pas que c'est ce que vous avez
fait mais on ne peut pas simplifié comme
ça facilement une cartographie médical
bien merci alors je vais donner la
parole aux membres de la commission
denquête incluant des questions à vous
poser puis après vous aurez chacun deux
minutes pour répondre et ajouter un
point que vous vous avez oublié qui vous
paraît important était alors allé vers
la clôture ensuite de cette table-ronde
tout à fait passionnante laurence cohen
oui bonjour à tout le monde et merci
pour l'apport que vous avez eue au
niveau de notre de notre commission
denquête je vais commencer par excusez
le fait que peut-être après avoir posé
messieurs valant que je parte parce que
je dois intervenir dans l'hémicycle donc
j'en suis désolé mais j'entendrai vos
réponses en regardant la la vidéo
d'abord je veux saluer je veux aussi
saluer tous et particulièrement le
docteur remo que j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer à laval et qu'il a montré
combien elle est engagée et passionnée
par son par son métier on voit bien que
il ya une disparité effectivement des
territoires mais que surtout il ya quand
même eu une
organisation de notre système de santé
avec les jets acheter etc qui a
complètement bouleversé le paysage et
qui a fermé bon nombre de d'hôpitaux de
proximité et quiches qui entraîne quand
même des conséquences moi je voudrais
vous poser des questions peut-être un
peu plus précise sur deux éléments
vous avez parlé de la fermeture de lits
c'est quand même quelque chose de retour
en il ya quelques temps il était
question de fermeture de lits par
rapport à la médecine ambulatoire
c'était un prétexte que moi je trouve
que c'est complémentaire et qu' on ne
doit pas fermer des lits parce qu'on
développe la halle à l'ambulatoire et
aujourd'hui on ferme des lits parce que
ya pas de personnel mais en tout cas moi
je pense qu'il ya besoin de vie à
l'hôpital voilà et donc à partir à
partir de là je viens sur le fait du
manque de personnel vous avez parlé du
numerus clausus en fait du numerus
clausus est pas vraiment si même si ça
s'est un peu desserré mais là la
responsabilité reporter sur les
universités il ya pas suffisamment
d'argent aux universités donc il va pas
y avoir un afflux de 2,2 de
professionnels formés donc il ya un
problème c'est vrai au niveau des pères
du personnel médical des personnels
médicaux et paramédicaux
donc ça c'est le premier point deuxième
point c'est sur l'attractivité moi il me
semble quand même que d'autres cas les
témoignages que j'ai que j'ai entendu
beaucoup c'est le faites ce que vous
avez dit épuisement conditions de
travail etc donc il faut faire revenir
aussi un certain nombre de personnels à
l'hôpital et pour ça donc il faut il
faut modifier le statut les conditions
de travail etc mais je pense qu'il ya
aussi des formations internes j'ai été
frappée je voulais savoir ce que vous en
pensez sur le fait qu' un exemple les
aides soignants qui aspirent à à devenir
infirmière qui devrait faire une
formation il elles dépendent du budget
de l'établissement et donc elles peuvent
faire postuler mais elles ne vont pas
obligatoirement pouvoir faire la
formation immédiatement parce que je dis
n'importe quoi l'enveloppent va
permettre que x par personne donc ça
sera peut-être l'année prochaine dans
deux ans dans trois ans moi je me dis
dans l'urgence dans laquelle on
aujourd'hui il faut absolument abondé
cesser ces enveloppes pour permettre à
ces personnes qui veulent trafic veulent
se former pour être à l'hôpital de faire
dès maintenant ce que même si c'est pour
trois ans si on ne fait pas maintenant
ça va encore reculer donc qu'est ce que
vous pensez au niveau de la formation
interne deuxième chose c'est au niveau
du du retour aussi des infirmières parce
qu'il ya pas mal d infirmières notamment
qui aujourd'hui sont libérales qui ont
quitté l'hôpital parce qu'elle n'en
pouvait plus là aussi si on travaille
sur leur statut si on travaille sur leur
salaire si on travaille sur les
conditions de travail je pense que pour
un certain nombre d'entre elles elles
elles pourraient revenir donc c'est je
voudrais vous entendre là dessus et la
dernière chose c'est sûr le poids de
l'administration
évidemment comme tout je suis d'accord
docteur doumeng c'est aussi une question
d'individus mais ça c'est l'humain c'est
partout sauf que pour même il ya une
quand même un haut niveau de cette
pesanteur de l'administration on
l'entend quand même partout avec des
protocoles qui sont vraiment figé dans
le marbre et qui font qu'aujourd'hui les
soignants en tout cas c'est ce qui nous
revient nous en tant que parlementaires
ont l'impression de passer plus de temps
devant l'ordinateur dans les fiches dans
le devant les les tableaux excel que au
chevet des patients ce pour quoi ils
sont ils sont faits et formés donc il ya
quand même un problème je veux dire il
faut quand même modifier cette
organisation et je voudrais là aussi
avoir votre point de vue parce que quand
même pendant la crise du comider vous
l'avait redit tout à l'heure eh bien il
ya eu une modification de l'organisation
à l'hôpital donc il faut réorganiser
l'hôpital ça c'est sûr mais pas le
réorganiser en prenant l'hôpital comme
une entreprise
alors véronique guillot temps
merci président en tout cas merci à vous
tous pour ces témoignages qui étaient
pour certains assez émouvant et qui ont
globalement
témoigner de la difficulté voire de la
souffrance plutôt de la difficulté que
vous éprouvez vous dans vos métiers moi
j'ai deux choses je vais dire ce qui m'a
semblé manquer
on n'a pas eu de l'hôpital on a parlé d
urgence et des difficultés qui était qui
étaient les vôtres par contre on a des
organisations qui existent aujourd'hui
donc c'est une question je vous pose
notamment les approches les
organisations populationnelle comme cc
pts je parle pas des j'ai acheté entre
hôpitaux je parle vraiment des
organisations populationnelle comme les
lycées pts quel rôle vous jouez vous
dansez cpts là est ce que vous pensez
que vous êtes suffisamment intégré et
moteur parce que je pense ou j'ai en
tout cas peut-être la faiblesse de
penser que ce ne sera que par une
approche plus large hôpitaux ville ont
parlé des sas alors dans certains
endroits il ya des maisons d'accueil
dans d'autres cas des maisons de santé
pluriprofessionnelle certaines jouent le
jeu qui d'autre ne font pas d'accueil de
soins non programmés par exemple
jusqu'au 22 23 heures ou 20 heures il ya
des endroits où les médecins traitants
ne font plus de gars on à sos deux
endroits où on les a pas faim voilà donc
je veux dire pour décharger l'hôpital
les urgences et avoir une première
réponse aux patients est ce que vous ne
pensez pas que cette organisation-là
devrait prendre plus de place et que
vous devez prendre peut-être plus de
place au sein de ces organisations
marie mercier
merci je voudrais tout d'abord vraiment
remercier et féliciter tous vous tous
les confrères qui vous est donné la
peine de venir ce matin et de répondre à
cette convocation puisque c'est vraiment
une convocation venir de clamecy ce
n'est pas aussi simple que ça n'est ni
venir de laval ce qui me permet de
switcher sur un rapport de force
administratif je pense que quand on est
à cochin
ce n'est pas du tout la même chose de
gérer ars que quand on est à clamecy
rien de penser ça on voit que c'est
différent c'est différent moi je suis en
saône-et-loire donc chalon sur saône qui
est quand même 1 un hôpital qui est
d'une très bonne taille et bien pour
s'adresser à l'air c'est déjà beaucoup
moins facile que ma famille ait le
parisienne qui est dans les hôpitaux
parisiens donc ça c'est déjà la première
chose ensuite il ya l'évolution de la
mentalité chez nos jeunes confrères nous
sommes ici de nombreux personnels de
santé nous ne sommes pas tout à fait de
la même génération mais j'ai vu déjà
entre la mienne et celle des tout
nouveaux que ce n'est pas la même chose
ils ont déjà ce virus de la culture
administrative qui est en eux c'est à
dire qu'ils ont envie de faire ce métier
comme nous l'avons fait mais quand même
encadrée avec des temps de travail on
voit des internes regardez leur ai dit
revenant mais moi je vais déjeuner et
plantes et les pelles on n'aurait jamais
fait ça de nouveau quand on faisait nos
études est-ce qu'on aurait même eu
l'idée l'idée de dire au patron qu était
là à temps que je vais manger mais
c'était même pas envisageable et ça et
ça se voit donc on ne peut pas les
critiquer c'est déjà très bien qu'on en
est parce que si on offre un visage
comme ça aussi triste de la médecine
c'est pas comme ça qu'on va la rendre
attractive et puis que que nos jeunes on
va les attirer dans ses merveilleux
métier mais à ce changement de mentalité
chez des jeunes qui est pour moi
essentiel quand on se baladait dans les
couloirs on voyait des infirmiers ou
avec d'ex avec des haricots avec des
plaques maintenant voit des gens avec
des dossiers sous le bras qui cours
d'une réunion à une autre alors ça ce
sont des témoignages vous n'êtes
probablement pas d'accord parce qu'on
peut être qu on ne va pas dans les mêmes
couloirs d'hôpitaux mais je vous assure
que la maltraitance administrative elle
est vraiment là il fait beaucoup de
dégâts parce qu'on a perdu pied avec la
réalité au moment du coc vide on s'est
dit ça y est on a remis les médecins au
coeur des décisions et je pense que
c'est ce qui se passe pour vous vous
êtes au coeur des décisions il me semble
que votre voix porte elle ne porte pas
partout c'est peut-être de la faute
personnelle des gens mais je pense quand
même que à partir du jour où on a décidé
que l'hôpital devait être
rentable presque et qu'on a coté à
l'activité c'est vrai que là on n'a pas
réévaluée depuis et qu'il faut il faut
je pense remédier aussi à ça donc je
pense que c'est pas tolérable en 2021
d'avoir des gens avec des fractures du
fémur c'est pas tolérable sur google
d'avoir des avis de patients qui
viennent dire untel untel sauf que tout
ça fait que ça donne une mauvaise image
de notre métier qui vend le plus beau
métier du monde mais en direction
d'autrui et que si soi même on n'est pas
très bien portants comme l'a dit notre
consoeur eh bien on ne fera pas une
qualité de soins ce qui sera suffisant
donc je pense qu'on a un potentiel
humain mais qu' il est quand même
beaucoup dégradés par cette
suradministration pathologique
merci allez vous allez avoir tous les
cinq la parole pour un temps bref car
nous sommes déjà en retard dans cette
table ronde que nous devons conclure
qu'il veut ouvrir dr yves nuage je peux
vous parler des cpts alors je me re
surtout que je suis membre de 2,2 c'est
pts
je comprends pas
à quoi ça sert
j'ai rien compris est une histoire de
réseau on est censé travailler ensemble
c'est ce qu'on fait tous les jours on
assez pts et mon téléphone portatif avec
les numéros de téléphone tous les
confrères le maximum qui me permet de
gérer ça j'ai un problème j'appelle xy
machin ça prend 20 secondes une cpts
donc j'espérais bien dans votre micro
battant d'un régisseur jeu parisien un
budget de plus de 350000 euros alors on
fait des réunions on fait des trucs mais
j'ai pas compris la valeur ajoutée de la
cps et je suis membre de officiellement
2 2 je vais à des réunions donne un peu
de sous à chaque fois mais je vois pas
là je vois pas l'intérêt c'est que c'est
le réseau passe est constitué au fil du
temps permettant d'avoir des
correspondants des confrères des gens
que l'on connaît et avec qui on
travaille ensemble
j'ai un problème pour placer quelqu'un
suivi j'appelle g où je connais la
serbie livre l'appel clac clac
généralistes le spécialiste ça marche
très bien il n'y a pas de ces pts donc
j'ai pas réellement compris à quoi ça
servait voilà et je suis dans deux
peut-être même trois fois
merci
dominque
en plusieurs éléments de réponses
d'abord je vais dans les mêmes hôpitaux
que 2m couloirs d'hôpitaux que tout le
monde ça y'a pas de souci là dessus et
que je suis aussi sur le terrain auprès
des équipes je pense que stigmatiser
encore une fois pierre paul ou jacques
ce fera jamais avancer les choses je
pense qu'en effet alors la rs mac
confrères dû s'absenter mais la grèce
très clairement je n'y ai jamais accès
parce que je ne suis jamais invité au
rayon de la rs personnellement donc
je n'empêche pas franchement de dormir
très clairement mais mes décisions je
peux cause par l'administration se pare
de l'administration locale locale aussi
on n'est pas obligé je parle dans le
fonctionnement au quotidien de son
hôpital des décisions évidemment qui
relève de la rs ford est tout à fait
d'accord ça sans commentaire et j'irai
enfin faut pas trop branché là dessus
parce que ça va être un peu compliqué
mais plus sérieusement en local on peut
modifier les choses donc c'est ça que je
veux dire aussi c'est ça mon message
madame disais tout à l'heure
l'entrerpise gérer un hôpital comme une
entreprise encore une fois quand on
parle du mot entreprises on a
l'impression d'être vulgaire et d'être
maltraitant il ya plein d'entreprises en
france qui traite parfaitement bien des
personnes qui travaillent et aussi les
personnes qui viennent donc je pense
qu'aussi ya peut-être un certain nombre
de choses qu'on peut prendre au monde de
l'entreprise dans la bonne quantité peut
côté des choses pour faire travailler
nos structures ensuite lui il disait il
parlait de la spécialité et aussi de la
fonction de chef de service
encore une fois depuis très longtemps et
là je vais rejoindre un petit peu ce qui
a été dit par rapport aux professeurs
avant pour être nommé chef de service
dans un service d'urgence par exemple il
fallait être professeur
et si on n'était pas professeur on
n'était pas nommé je suis l'exemple
typique d'un médecin généraliste
praticiens hospitaliers mis en pl mis à
la poste de chefferie de service avec
son adjoint qui est professeur des
universités et donc j'ose espérer
simplement qu'on a été mis là
elle et moi peut-être par nos
compétences et en fait on a on n'a pas
été mis là simplement parce qu on est on
est bien né ou parce qu'on a juste les
diplômes machin c'est parce qu'on a on
nous a audité on a des compétences et
donc je crois que ça c'est aussi
important que les gens comprennent qu'il
faut mettre aussi à la tête de services
d'urgence et dans la beaucoup de
services d'urgence oui en est la
parfaite illustration on met en place
des gens qui savent entre guillemets
manager qui sont en capacité si les
discuter avec l'administration pour
pouvoir discuter r sur des sur des
points précis et c'est comme ça je pense
qu'on peut s'en sortir donc on a aussi
ce mode de 2 0
merci professeur cela
alors d'abord pour ce qui est du temps
de travail
je pense qu'on est tous convaincus
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas un problème qui
impacte le changement générationnel
n'est pas un problème qu'il ya pas que
les deux professions de santé bon
je pense que je suis un de ceux qui fait
le plus d'heures poster d'un service peu
pour essayer de faire quelques indique
sont supportables pour les autres mais
c'est un message le côté on donne
l'exemple ça n'a plus lieu aujourd'hui
il ya un changement complètement
générationnel il faut faire avec et je
pense que c'est un pas que toutes les
professions jeunes appert que des
boulangers je pense qu'aujourd'hui les
boulangers non plus une condition de
travail qui à 50 ans on est obligé de
faire avec et c'est peut-être qu'en
raison c'est ce que me dit toujours mon
épouse de personnellement le pour ce qui
est des cp tss pts mais moi j'y crois
j'y crois parce que
c'est c'est quand même ce qui permet un
petit peu de fédérer des activités des
métiers de la santé dans le dans la
ville enfin l'extérieur de l'hôpital et
je trouve que ça apporte une dynamique
très intéressante nous on a quatre cpt à
se constituer on en a quatre autres en
projet sur le département
d'ille-et-vilaine et et le sens ne
pourra marcher que si la cpt s
fonctionne de 7 pts c'est quoi c'est
essayer un petit peu de
2,2 de regrouper certains des réseaux
qui existent déjà et non pas uniquement
des médecins des soignants des
pharmaciens ça peut être aussi des
claviers de radio l'idée c'est de
pouvoir mutualiser une offre de soins et
la mettre à disposition des patients
justement ceux qui n'ont pas le médecin
traitant donc c'est très théorique tout
ça mais moi j'y crois et ça marche et au
moins ça permet un dialogue alors après
c'est vrai que le pour l'hôpital c'est
sa participation mais c'est un peu
contraignant parce qu'il faut un petit
peu aller au-devant en lien avec les
collègues de la permanence des soins
mais je ne peux pas faire de bilan pour
l'instant c'est trop récent le concept
alors c'est des maisons de santé cds msp
plus pourquoi pas mais je pense qu'il ya
quelque chose ce même attendre il faut
les laisser un petit peu se développer
d'autant plus que la dynamique des
salles n'est pas encore généralisée
vous avez parlé de la fermeture des lits
alors oui les fermetures des dix c'est
un
vrai problème parce qu'on ferme d'eads
et aujourd'hui donc pas parce que
c'est sûr par manque de soignants sur
tout et ça c'est très grave parce que il
ya un vrai besoin de dix on a mis
quelques années à comprendre que les
organisations dit
qu'ils étaient faites aux des eaux au
profit des organisations d'hôpital de
joueurs de pétales de semaine donc ces
fermetures de lits et on l'a payé cher
avec levier sur la population parce que
les patients ont changé avec levier sur
la pollution notamment donc aujourd'hui
on se rend compte et ça a été le cas
trop vite qu'on manque de souplesse sous
l'ouverture des lits on est complètement
sûr des organisations il faut il faut
ben ali il faut tendre soignants talent
mais aujourd'hui il faut des
organisations beaucoup plus agile pour
répondre aux variations au pic
saisonnier de titrisation mais
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'il ya des
digues dans certaines structures alors
je suis bien attention à ce que je dis
pas ce que
arènes y ait eu des créations 10 mai qui
ont rattrapé un retard qui aujourd'hui
est encore insuffisant puisqu'il faut en
créer d'autres essais surpris des lits
de médecine polyvalente qu'il faut créer
et non plus des lits hyperspécialisés
donc peut-être qu'il faut revoir
complètement notre système de gestion
des lits aux états unis il n'y a pas de
lit affecte un service il ya délit qui
sont à disposition et les spécialités en
prennent en fonction des besoins par
contre dès libre pour prendre en charge
un patient dans sa spécialité oui c'est
complètement indispensable une fracture
du col du fémur dont on parlait tout à
l'heure à 95 ans certes il faut l'opérer
mais il faut savoir aussi pourquoi les
tombes et à son domicile et pourquoi
elle peut plus rester à son domicile
dans les mêmes conditions qu'avant sa
chute donc ces fermetures de lits c'est
un vrai problème et c'est aujourd'hui on
en parle beaucoup parce que il ya des
lits manquent de personnel et c'est un
cercle vicieux et c'est vrai que s'il
n'y a pas de libre les patients restent
aux urgences et personnels s'épuisent et
s'en vont il faut les faire revenir vous
avez parlé également de formation ouais
je suis moins d'accord c'est
complètement anormal que ce soit aussi
compliqué pour eux pour qu'une
infirmière qui donnent satisfaction
social gerry's et je connais l'hôpital à
côté de rennes très ou trois infirmières
vont changer d'orientation parce que on
leur sont pas stage et reese est donc
c'est complètement anormal le système
trop rigide moi j'ai un médecin qui est
qui a fait la paix 1
son dossier a été bouclé par la deuxième
année consécutive au cng pour raison lui
demande de faire signer polyvalente
alors qu'il savait trois ans qui
travaillait médecine polyvalente on a un
système beaucoup trop rigide et
effectivement il ya tout ce qui est en
promotion interne qu'il faut favoriser
je parlais de mes ambulancier smur tout
à l'heure je tiens mais pourquoi pas
cette reconnaissance il ya trop de
grille salariale on nous pose des
catégories entre elles pour les
progressions de grille salariale sur des
trucs qui sont complètement obsolète
merci professeur docteur ou bien
alors je vais parler de mon expérience
de terrain on est vraiment j'ai essayé
de faire passer le message concernant
les cocistes un mec de complètement
différent
la cpt elle était constituée chez nous
il ya à peu près il ya un peu moins d'un
an d'ailleurs c'est un des médecins de
clamecy dynamique qui est à la tête de
la cps à
moi je suis sur le principe je suis tout
à fait d'accord puisque si ça permet de
fluidifier les relations avec le la
médecine de ville c'est l'idéal sauf que
chez nous en zone rurale
les médecins ils sont concentrés à
clamecy
éparpillés un peu partout sur le
territoire en quantité largement
insuffisante donc sur le principe
théorique c'est très bien j'attends que
ça soit réévaluée dans les zones rurales
non je sais pas pour les villes donc
voilà donc moi je suis je suis d'accord
mais à condition qu'on réévalue
on réveille s'estimant que je pense en
france on ne réévalue pas voilà pourquoi
continuer à s'entêter à utiliser un
système qui marche pas une fois qu'on a
fait le diagnostic nous médecins au
quotidien
concrètement fonctionnement passe à
autre chose pourquoi ça serait pas la
même chose au niveau des projets
pourquoi
alors je reviens je m'adresse aux
le ss pour l'instant l'hôpital de lons
est en rapport avec la cpt à l'hôpital
de dons classé pts
l'élément de la cps de clam siens qui
couvre le nord le nord de lanières
touché un territoire très vaste
rural qui dépasse le territoire de
clamecy çà çà çà bords de la loire
jusqu'à cosne sur loire
il ya aucun établissement
qui à de la chirurgie ya aucun
établissement sur ce toutou ce
territoire qui a de la spécialité ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il faut
établir des relations qui vont au delà
du territoire de la cpt est ce ça
complique encore les choses je vous
disais toujours filière de soins filière
du serait encore plus important dans les
zones rurales si on raisonne pas à
cochin à rennes n'est pas de difficultés
fondamentalement à savoir où se trouvent
les spécialistes même s'ils sont
surbookés nous on en a pas et les délais
pour y aller son
incommensurable
ça correspond à des choses qui
paraissent inhumaine
donc voilà ça c'est quelque chose qui
est très difficile à faire comprendre
par mes collègues qui ont toujours vécu
dans le système hospitalo universitaires
je sais que monsieur soula a vécu il a
fait l'essentiel de sa carrière dans un
hôpital de de pivot où il a développé de
très très belles choses dans le domaine
cardiologie voilà donc il faut tenir
compte de sa filière de soi cpt cdd des
choses qui peuvent apporter un plus mais
attention ce sera adapté à des zones où
la démographie médicale permet de créer
ce lien entre l'hôpital moi je suis pour
le décloisonnement suis pour les
pratiques partagées un besoin d'insister
sur la capacité de métier ignorance et
pas un combat d'arrière garde le cuir
sous là c'est moi je considère que ce
n'est pas un combat d'arrière-garde
parce qu'au niveau de la formation
effectivement ça dure deux ans et moins
lourd que les quatre ans de formation de
la spécialité qui devaient être connus
en tant que pour la médecine d'urgence
mais mais mais ça permet de rendre les
gens opérationnels avec une obligation
de formation continue moi je suis désolé
une capacité de médecine d'urgence une
capacité médecine de catastrophe et cas
l'obligation de faire des débuts en
échographie
dd on promet le polytraumatisé etc il a
avec l'expérience
il a suffisamment de 2,2 de capacité à
prendre en charge les urgences dans les
territoires où on sait à l'avancé
que les jeunes médecins qui sont formés
en quantité insuffisante avec ce nouveau
délai ce qui est une avancée qualitative
ans ils n'iront pas travailler dans les
zones périphériques voilà merci docteur
ou bien docteur brémaud alors je vais
faire court qu pour ce qui concerne
l'organisation délier la formation je
partage complètement le propos de louis
soûlât
concernant les dispositifs je pense que
n'importe quel dispositif peut être
intéressant mais si on ne communique pas
dessus ça sert à rien donc s'il faut
connaître et maîtriser les dispositifs
et il faut travailler sur la
communication en interne il faut
travailler sur la lourdeur la lourdeur
administrative est en fait il faut aussi
communiquer vers l'extérieur mais vers
lecteurs c'est entre soignant vers la
population vers le médico social c'est
vraiment la communication entre tous les
partenaires et si on n'arrive pas à
faire cette comme parce que il ya trop
de bonheur lourdeurs administratives
parce qu'on est surchargé par notre
temps de travail et que du coup là comme
c'est ce qu'on verrait temps dernier sur
la liste des choses qu'on a à faire on
n'arrivera pas parce qu'un n'importe
quel dispositif s'il existe mais que
personne ne le connaît il sert à rien
donc je pense que c'est ça aussi nez et
on ne savons pas nous à l'école de
médecine à communiquer et
cette année chez eux j'ai étudié à
l'école des hautes études de santé
publique qui formaient directeur à le
hcsp rennes j'ai la chance d'avoir été
admise dans cette école pour un an pour
faire un d eux de deux médecins manager
et j'apprends le langage des
administratifs parce qu'en fait je n'en
parle pas le même langage on peut pas se
comprendre donc déjà c'est la base que
nous on rentre dans leurs locaux et
qu'on apprenne à se parler et à eux qui
viennent en fait vivre un petit peu en
une version donc que j'ai rencontré les
directeurs formidable qu'ils
maîtrisaient le langage médical et je
pense que c'est ce qui manque c'est des
interactions entre entre nous et ce qui
ce qui se passe là je suis à ce pc c'est
un bel exemple de ce qu'on peut faire et
ce qu'il va nous aider
[Musique]